the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
you don't discuss business at the table
but it's all business over the boards at
the U.S women's and U.S open
championships in St Louis watching the
country's top players in the capital of
Chess is an offer you can't refuse
defending champ Wesley so is playing
like a boss again taking out elshon
Moore diobody in a sicilian opening
Talia Cervantes is shooting her way to
the top winning her fourth game in a row
we're beating a dead horse but the
leaders remain the same will anyone
emerge to threaten their title hopes day
12 of Novel chess coming up next
[Music]
all right
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 12 of the
2022 us chess championships and U.S
women's chess Championships held here in
St Louis we started the day in front of
the Arts Museum as we are waiting for
the players to arrive there's been a lot
of artistic expression for the last
couple of weeks here in St Louis who's
going to come on top let's go to the
studio and start today's action with
Yasser and anastasi from the home of
Chess in the United States welcome to
the Saint Louis chess club and the 12th
round of the USGS championships and the
yes women's chess championships
foreign
[Music]
four times U.S champion and The
Grandmaster yeah sir hello how are you
doing today I am doing well Anastasia
good to see you I'm having so much fun
calling the action and the determination
of The Players yesterday Lanier 131
moves and he managed to win the game
until
my goodness that was really quite
something hello everyone and thank you
for joining our show indeed we are in
the championship rounds today is the
penultimate round tomorrow the last and
final round it's during these rounds
that a tournament is made or broken who
is going to win well first of all let's
take a look at our leaderboards not to
flog a dead horse but are our leaders
still the same in the ladies yes exactly
just for you who has eight points out of
11 uh and Lena cross just follows her
step with seven and a half only half a
point behind her on the second place
Talia Cervantes won four games in a row
and jumped on the third position clear
third place for sale and Alice Lee is on
the first place the youngest
participants still fighting for the best
places in the tournament very nice and
in the open section what's our
leaderboard look like there Fabiano
caruana keeps leading with seven and a
half points and rare Robson is on the
clear second place was seven points we
have some changes linear Domingo soon
same seven who won their games yesterday
jumped on the third position now they
are tied for the third place and they're
followed by the group of also you know
Rivals right just in the mix yes Jeffrey
Jones Franklin a Wonderland they're
really looking forward you know and try
to catch the leaders absolutely and our
foreman format for these two national
championships Anastasia we have 14
players in each tournament it's round
robin system so everybody will meet with
everyone all right 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves followed by 30 minutes
for the rest of the game and we also
have 30 seconds increment from move one
and no draw offers everybody fights
until the end and our remaining schedule
is not much yes only two rounds to go
today we have around 12 and tomorrow the
last round 13s and if needed if we have
time for the first place we'll have
players on October 20 dentist as well as
the closing ceremony which will take
place at 6 PM a little more details on
the closing ceremony please everybody
can join the ceremony everybody who is
in St Louis at least these days you can
just buy the ticket for 25 and then you
can visit the closing ceremony as well
as cocktails party and after party after
the awarding part and if you are not in
St Louis you can still join join the
live stream on YouTube channel and as
always we are very fortunate to have in
studio a dear friend Christian Christian
deal a drill down on the players are
leaders and tell us what they're facing
good to see you my friend good to see
you guys great to be back in the studio
as we enter the last championship rounds
it's all about those last few drops of
energy left in the tank of our players
and let's take a look at where our
leaders are standing right now we're
going to start with the open section and
one Grandmaster Ray Robson he's been
having a stellar events so far three
wins eight draws and absolutely a no
losses he also crossed for the first
time in his career the 2700 rating
barrier just an impressive performance
for this young man and let's take a look
at his road ahead for the last couple of
rounds today a big opportunity in my
opinion despite the fact that he's
playing the black pieces he's playing
against a struggling player and that is
Christopher you you guys were talking
about his matchup with Lanier Dominguez
that lasted 130 moves yesterday and he
actually lost that one so
psychologically he's going to be in a
rough situation this is a big chance for
Rey with the black pieces and tomorrow
in the final round the championship
round with the white pieces against
Jeffrey Sean but he still has to catch
up with our leader Fabiano caruana a
stellar event for him as well he is
winning actually Four rating points and
Matthew level four rating points are not
easy to win four wins seven draws zero
losses plus four for the tournament and
right now half a point in the lead and
let's take a look at his road ahead
because I have to say this one is quite
difficult especially today with the
black pieces against the 2018 us
Champion Sam Shanklin that one is going
to be a big fight and of course the last
one these players know each other so
well in the final round they are
actually quite good friends he will be
having the white pieces against levonne
aronian
couple of uh well actually one of our
leader and tatev abrahamian who is
struggling in her event but definitely
having a lot of fun here at the U.S
chess championships these guys are
having well they're maintaining a very
positive attitude we know that they are
extremely tired I mean we are tired as
commentators as well these guys have
been under severe tension for the last
couple of weeks but right now you know
they look relaxed chatty a big big game
for tative as well but let's take a look
at what's happening in the ladies
section because we have some big
matchups coming your way especially in
round 12. this is the match of the
tournament the one Between Women
Grandmaster Jennifer you against a-time
National Champion Irina Crush two wins
zero losses and one drop for Jennifer I
have to say she's quite dominant in this
matchup and if she wins today's game she
might actually clinch the title with
around one round to a spare that depends
on other results as well but she has a
huge chance and let's take a look at
what's happening tomorrow for one Irina
Crush because she has today a very
difficult matchup but tomorrow as well
she's finishing with the white pieces
against Anna zatonski and we know they
have such an incredible rivalry for the
last 10 20 years here at the US chess
championships Arena crush and Anna
satonski no matter how their events are
going how their respective events are
going this one is always going to be a
critical and explosive matchup and how
about Jennifer you in the last round
well she has a difficult one as well
against the Sergey Talia Cervantes and
we can see this one is a very stable
matchup two wins two losses and two
draws and Talia is surging she has won
her last four games she's just in
incredible shape right now I mean this
is going to be a fiery finish in both
sections guys saving the best for last
exactly and Anastasia do the honors tell
our viewers what they can expect for all
the pairings let's start with the ladies
let's start with the ladies and we have
on the top uh the game between uh first
place and second place Jennifer you will
play against Arena crash that's of
course the main our main focus and then
we have the bottom of this standings we
have Thalia Cervantes facing uh begin
the herdronova today another great
matchup I think so especially that beg
him is trying of course still to fight
for the best places in the tournament
and we can see also Ellis Lee who face
Sabina for sure and in the opens one of
the key matchups there yes the leader of
the tournament will play again yes and
then we can see also Ray Robson also he
plays with black pieces against
Christopher you and two players who
share the third position will play
against the leader Dominguez hope
against Jefferson right and same
very very nice matchups they've been
fighting really really hard these last
few weeks as we get ready for this
penultimate Showdown we see Tata at the
board the players still coming into the
club they go through that security
wanding check is all part of the fair
play rules here in St Louis but uh what
are they playing for in terms of prize
funds let's go with the ladies first
rounds to go it's really time to check
the prices once again for everyone and
for the players themselves because every
half a point will matter now because the
winner will get 40 000 and the total
price fund is 160 500 160 500 dollars
so the second place also get really
decent thirty thousand third place
twenty thousand really great prices for
women event absolutely thank you I'm
enjoying every time I see this these
numbers thank you St Louis thank you St
Louis chess club and in the open section
very handsome prize money uh there as
well yes 262
000 a total prize fund the champion of
America will get 60 000 and then for the
second place uh the player will get 45
and then 35 and all the way to 14's
place with 5500. and there you see
Jennifer you are tournament leader in
the ladies section getting wandered
coming into this penultimate round Sam
Sabian just behind her and Ray Robinson
the leaders are a bit lazy you know
maybe they were preparing until the very
end you know exactly now in these you
know we talk about how you could play a
five hour game and one single move could
cost you that half a point or the full
point well that's the way it is also in
the tournament you could play a terrific
tournament you could do really really
well and these last two rounds could
spoil a very very very nice event or uh
you know it could just turn it into a
tragedy and these two rounds I mean you
feel the tension too don't you oh yes of
course yeah Anastasia when you've got
your butterflies are a little bit more
more active more active exactly yeah not
in detention actually yes it's really
important these are always very
important days I don't know yeah sir if
you enjoyed to play the last channels
when you were fighting for the best
prices or yes yes places which would
just as you said the butterflies were
more active that's just the way it is
and you have to enjoy it I mean yes you
worked so hard and you actually managed
to get in the position to have this
butterflies yeah because you could be
fighting for the last position and then
you wouldn't have too many bottles what
you would want is for the tournament to
end but at least you're in in the right
position and you should be happy with
that situation yeah this event was such
a good price money you even enjoy
fighting sometimes even for the Lost
places
exactly I just noticed that when
Jennifer came down I came and sat down
she she went on her score sheet and Drew
a kind of line in between uh usually
that's for a time but I I really enjoyed
it was uh Juan Bayonne Grandmaster
Bayonne from Spain he would come and
literally with crayons he would make
these colors uh on his scoresheet like
the first 10 moves the next 10 moves and
it all get you know go yellow blue and
then the last 10 moves were red because
it was like he was he knew he was going
to get into time trouble he
had this color code it was pretty pretty
funny and we have one D4 one Knight F6
now in that matchup Christian you showed
that uh Arena has a bad score with
Jennifer but Jennifer was saying that
she had black and it was like Arena was
coming out after her to explain her but
I can guarantee you Irina is coming
after her in this moment she wants to
win this game with the black pieces and
she was mentioning that during the
interview yeah what a great attitude
yeah this is going to be a good
opportunity for me to actually write
that score right that wrong right I've
been losing against this young player
it's time to punish this youngsters C7
C5 okay for me this is an invitation
after D5 to play the bank I don't think
she's going to see the benoni you think
so that's even more dangerous I I agree
I I bet on the benoni but let's see yeah
well here it comes D5 The Gauntlet has
been laid she's not shy
taking up
yeah
no we were both wrong it may well
transpose it but it will be a better it
will be a benoni it's just going to be a
late benoni okay E6 maybe E5 as well
even though E5 in general
in fact does it make a lot of sense to
start off with G6 because
I know it makes a lot of sense to do
that if the Knight is still on G8 and
then you can play E6 and actually get
the Knight to E7 but now with the Knight
already on F6 I'm not sure why she's
doing this this particular move order
well that's what I wanted to say the
funny part was that Talia who will be uh
Jennifer Yu's opponent tomorrow Talia
has in a repertoire uh the four pawns
attack
against the king's Indian so after uh D6
Italia just absolutely loves uh this uh
double edge uh opening oh
we have two very late arrivals in this
empty table and it's better to play with
black in such situations because White's
clock has been started Jeffrey Jean no
he's actually hasn't no Jeffrey has
played his move oh so Jeffrey Jeffries
Jeffrey arrived here and he's waiting
for living here for linear
Lanier who enjoys using all of his clock
right he's a little late
Indiana Jones somehow well I I was
thinking World War One fighter pilot
if you want to go with the
anthropologist
nice
all right time's running and away he
goes uh what's caught your eye thus far
uh Christian in the penultimate round oh
I was just looking at what's happening
in the ladies section of course we've
seen what happened in the journey for
you that one is going to be a big fight
this one uh we need to keep an eye on as
well beg him versus Talia because once
again Talia is on Seven Points one point
behind Jenny for you but she's been
surging in the event the last four
rounds she has been Majestic in her
execution and right now she's playing
with the black pieces a player against
whom she doesn't have a very good score
she actually lost a couple of games
against begging I think in the U.S chess
championships last year as well as in
one of those Grand Master invitationals
held here at the St Louis chess club so
now we have this particular uh game
right now and of course we know Talia in
general is a gruffal player and uh if
she is a goofball player if she stays
true to her nature she's going to
probably go D5 she actually doesn't play
too often this move C6 and goes into
that that hybrid between a slav and a
groover so in general we see a D5 from
her of course D6 is also an option to
try to transition into more of a king's
Indian setup but then I'm just simply
going to go D4 and if you don't play The
King's Indian and we don't that Talia
doesn't play it at least not as often as
she does uh the gruffal then she might
have some trouble in the opening let's
wait and see what she's going to choose
C6 D6 or D5 if she stays through to her
nature she will pay the move D5 this one
is going to be very intriguing
thank you for that I just noticed by the
way in the game between tatv and
Rochelle
to have played uh well a little bit off
the Beaten Track this move Queen D1 D3 I
think Queen D2 is
such a main main main main move that
almost the other things are just kind of
distractions Queen D3 a little bit of a
wrinkle here I mean it gives the queen
an opportunity to come over to G3
whether the queen will be well placed
there or not that's a different question
castles yeah we can ask questions for 95
right just
I'm going to be very curious to see how
this queen D3 works out
for uh tatef in this game but let's jump
to our open section and just see uh what
our tournament leader Christopher you
and Ray Robson are doing well Ray has
said hey look I'm not going to deviate
from what's brought me success this far
Berlin castles Knight takes E4 rookie
one now rookie one is if I'm going to
play for a draw in the Berlin yes I'm
playing this this is a movie this is
like this is like almost a stone cold
guarantee Knight takes E5 Bishop E7
Bishop F1 so many games have been played
and we've got Knight takes E5 Rook takes
E5 on the board followed by castles and
we will likely see Knight C3 and or D4
are the main moves for white and because
of the four verses four three versus
three the open e-files it's like The
Chopping Block everything gets traded on
the e-file and draws of the most common
result now the big matchup was between
Fabi and Sam Shanklin and the question
is can Sam couldn't get an advantage out
of the opening the only thing I can tell
you that Sam at least he's very fresh
today he had almost two free days right
there was a free day yesterday he made a
quick drawn and so he had lots of time
to prepare for this kid his energy
should be soaring right exactly yes so
actually it has two white pieces uh you
know in a row right so he had yesterday
will he be able to use white pieces
today let's say so-called advantage of
white pieces exactly so uh symmetrical
uh English with d7d5 early D7 D5 and
we've seen Knight C3 Queen pardon me
Knight C3 Knight C7 earlier in the
tournament we've seen these D4 uh
endings uh earlier in the tournament and
I think pardon me uh this was not played
pardon me uh it's Queen Knight C3 G6
Queen A4
whoa something new well it's there it's
been around it's a little bit off the
Beaten Track over to you Christian a
little bit so I've actually analyzed
this uh from the black site because I
play the groomfield and sometimes they
can uh trick me into post position and
sometimes against C4 I like to open up
with C5 as well and go from the English
setup now the idea of this queen to A4
is that I immediately have a big threat
and that is the most Knight to E5 right
right for example if you play something
like let's say H6 right Knight to E5
pretty much kills the game right now
you're losing at least the point you
have to take back on C3 then the Knight
on C6 is going to be lost you're going
to lose at least a pawn and a very
important Pawn so you have to defend
against that now how do you do it if you
try to get a this Knight off diagonal
still Knight to E5 is a problem so you
have to start with Bishop to G7 it seems
like and now there's a couple of options
if you do go with the natural Castle now
I have time to get this Knight out of
touch and play this move Knight to C7
because Knight to E5 is no longer an
option so in general instead of Castle
actually this has been seen at the elite
level between Wesley so and mvl and I do
believe that this was the game that I
was basing my repertoire on as well
Knight to G5 and this is a critical
position now to B6 is an option to give
a pawn like this Knight B6 take on C6
take on C6 take on C6 Bishop to D7 and
I'm just saying that I will have enough
compensation based on uh the activity of
my pieces as well as the lack of the
light Square Bishop in your position as
white so you would have some problems on
the king side now
there's also this move
E6 just simply defend the pawn the
Knight on D5 you can go Knight to E4 and
after Knight B6 Queen to C2 or queen to
B5 as well if I'm not mistaken it was
Queen to B5 that was played yes that was
the move played in Wesley so versus mvl
and I think it was Castle in this
position or to move C4 C4 actually this
was the move C4 and Knight to E4 Knight
to A4 and at some point the pawn on C4
was lost nevertheless black has a lot of
compensation for the pawn because after
Castle you will see this Knight landing
on D4 once you take on C4 the C file
opens up I have ideas of Bishop to D7
Rook to C8 and putting a lot of pressure
on the C file there's a lot of
compensation in the position for example
you don't even have to go C4 you can go
Castle take on C5 Knight to D4 Queen to
D3 and now the other Knight is coming
towards the C2 Square Knight before
Knight C2 lots of compensation for the
pawn but we know how well prepared Sam
Shanklin is so I'm very curious to see
what ideas he has in mind he was not
happy with yesterday's game we know he's
actually a proponent of playing for the
win with the white pieces against
anybody in the world against the world
champion yes I will play for a win I do
not want to make a quick draw just
because I have the white pieces and he
was very upset with the result in
yesterday's game against Levon aronia So
today we're expecting something big from
Sam and I'm kind of surprised that
Fabiano is actually thinking at this
point what is he thinking about maybe
he's thinking about the move E6 that
would surprise me I think Bishop to G7
should come but it does seem like Sam
Shanklin has won the Battle of the
opening I think he's just trying to
remember his files yeah sometimes it's
not successful
exactly sometimes you wake up and it's
just not there what do I play with this
position again yes and you try to
remember some people they have this good
memory yes visual memory so like they
even remember which page it's in the in
which that is crazy of course there was
one move that you didn't really discuss
Bishop G7 is natural I mean absolutely
also Knight B6 uh just say look why did
you develop your queen Knight B6 is a
move as well and then once again my
whole premise is to try to get the pawn
for all this expansion exactly and then
Knight D7 and you just say yes yes okay
yes
I don't give you the pawn I think you're
a bit too passive like okay I I just
don't think this is in the spirit of the
position so right now I will just go D3
and maybe when you put the bishop G7
right even try ideas uh such as H4 and
try to put pressure on that side like
this I still think white has an
advantage in this position so in general
I don't want to do this I want to give
you the pawn and get the compensation
for it this is in the spirit of this
type of
um let's say hybrids between the
groomfield and the English setup with C5
very very interesting middle game
position arising in this one well in the
spirit of Brotherhood and happiness I
want to take your Pawn
I want to make everybody happy that's
why I don't go
Bishop G7 first you're convinced you
have to do some more by the way E7 E6 on
the board six is on the board wow kind
of inviting 95. we'll keep an eye on
that I want to just turn our attention
quickly to two games first game Lanier
Dominguez on the outside looking in come
on somebody stop Abby somebody stop Ray
I just got plus two isn't that wonderful
I'm playing I didn't lose any game let's
say I will try my best to push against
the yes against the field and Jeffrey so
again most of my career Queens Gambit
accepted has been a part of my
repertoire so I whenever I see my
repertoire being played I'm always very
curious as to you know where it's going
to go E2 E4 mainly I have played in my
career in Knight F6 I've also dabbled in
E5 but almost never I mean like I've
never gone down this road because I was
always afraid of the move A4 I have to
play uh C6
A6 unfortunately uh just is a terrible
uh move for black so C6 takes takes and
I've always thought well gee after
Knight C3 I have to play this lousy move
Queen B6 and after B3 like what to play
now everything like falls apart right
I'm losing back my pond
uh I've developed my queen early I'm
starting to worry about moves like
Knight D5 and and falling behind in
development and I just never went any
further than this like this was mine
enough is enough yeah there's enough not
to play exactly I pulled the parachute
and Lanier just took it and said no no
no no no no let's play I'll stop Knight
D5 5 with the movie 76 I played B3 for a
reason I I have to follow through Bishop
that's a that's a nasty pin yes Bishop
D2 and uh I'm assuming we don't want to
play Queen takes D4 Knight F3 and
eventually white will win back the pawn
and this is going to be nice for white
so linear captured Bishop takes played
Knight E7 and he's just sitting there
saying okay I'm gonna go castles I'm
gonna go A7 A5 Knight C6 and convince me
that I have
upon weakness five versus five so I'm
just like wow this is really kind of uh
opening my eyes to new possibilities
because I would have never gone for this
20 30 years ago
no no maybe they analyzed it then they
think there's just let's say equal
position or possible position to play
and uh I wanted to jump to you uh
Christian because Christopher you
sacrificing an exchange say what do you
remember when you said that yeah if
Christopher you plays this uh
he just wants to make a drug that's what
he's not looking to make it wrong right
unbelievable this to youngsters you know
you play 131 moves game you lose and no
next day you want to beat your opponent
but that opens up the door for Ray
Robson potentially to get the full point
as well and catch up maybe even surpass
Fabiano caruana depending on that result
so tell us check this out Bishop to F6
Bishop D3 and this has been played
recently in fact but mostly in Rapid
competition Not In classical chess so if
Ray knows Knight to C3 D6 is a critical
move which was played by the way Queen
to H5 you have to defend against the
Checkmate there's only one way to do it
G6 if you go H6 after Bishop takes H6
F6 or F5 Bishop to H7 oh sorry Queen H7
F6 is Checkmate but f55 Queen G6 King h8
and now uh probably something like
bishopsis
wow
right of course so you cannot do that
you have to you have to go G6 now I have
to get the queen to H6 right because I
need to start setting up things such as
Bishop to G5 followed by Bishop to F6
right put the grip on your position like
that a couple of moves that black can
play here and I have to
um I have to say I think it was Queen to
E7 which was no never mind it was Bishop
to E6 there's this game between pretke
and kovalev yes 2016. I think this was
uh the big one Bishop to E6 Bishop to G5
and now Queen to D7
and the question is how do you develop
your attack Knight to F6 this has a good
start right if you take your knight to
F6 finishes the game Checkmate you take
take there's no way to defend against
Queen to G7 so that one is game over and
by the way the queen is already on H6 it
seems like they are following this line
so there's only one defense you have to
go F5 right in the position now if you
take at least there's no more Knight to
F5 I sacrificed the pawn you have a lot
of compensation but you don't have the
Checkmate coming anytime soon in the
position so now I can just simply go
Bishop to F5 try to eliminate some
pieces and play the position as such
I'm wondering what does Christopher you
have in mind or is this like a semi
gamble in the position maybe he's
affected by the fact that he lost maybe
he didn't look at any new ideas up until
this morning maybe he was very upset at
night and he didn't have time to find a
clear-cut way to put some pressure with
the white pieces and then he decided
okay let's just gamble today
you were what about this game you were
mentioning what was the result let's say
because probably why it still has some
kind of compensation and by the way
there is another game in 2022 and this
is why I know this line because it was
also played by my student
and I I told him that somebody will play
this line against him and we started
looking at this and he analyzed it he
kind of find the right way to arrange
his pieces as black and it seems like he
didn't have any problems to not only
equalize but actually win with the black
pieces comfortably so this is key you
have to go Bishop P6 then F5 that's one
way I'm wondering if Queen to E7 also
works in the position if I remember
correctly Queen to E7 was working but it
was giving white some a very decent
compensation take on these things with
the Knight Bishop to G5 long term
compensation on the dark swears Bishop
to F4 you get the queen to G7 then I go
back to uh G5 or I have even ideas of
Knight to D5 right involve my knight
into the attack you cannot take on H6
because after Bishop takes H6 you
actually lose on C7 and you lose the
exchange as well so it's not looking
good for you in the position very
interesting and by the way if you do
this I can do this check this out and
now Bishop to F6 is an interesting idea
there is a checklist right you have to
go H6 and then I will take on C7 Knight
F5 doesn't work because of Bishop takes
F5 so there's a lot of intriguing lines
in this one array has to be very precise
but if he is and if he knows his
preparation if I remember correctly
there's not much
um as white but once again Rey has to
find a very precise moves to get out of
this initial bind that white has set up
on dark swears on the king side yeah
well it's pretty simple he's a half a
point behind he has to score if he loses
there goes the championship a good prize
no question about that but he's got a
score he's got to make at least a draw
a win of course is uh brilliant but it's
that simple uh Queen D7 is it a
um is it a
how do you say uh is white taking a big
risk in this exchange sacrifice again
it's going to be like a long-term
compensation uh so that's why probably
Christopher is playing this one I mean
if you're not really losing with white
but it's not specialization for equality
you will be worse he will be worse yes
you will be worse it takes some risks
that was my question it's a semi gamble
that gamble I would say like 40 60 40
60. I see so it all depends if I array
maybe check this position before if it's
if he feels comfortable in this position
so it's not only about the evaluation
sometimes players really don't like this
situation when somebody attacks them
from the very beginning like you change
the track of the game you play this
variation you think okay I have a draw
here most probably it's very calm
variation and then suddenly your
opponent gives you an exchange and tells
you okay now yeah I know that probably
I'm worse here maybe I'm gambling a
little bit but still I have some chances
you know if you play one move
unprecisely exactly
is very precise in his uh defense and
actually we spoke with Fabiano caruana
in one of the interviews a few days ago
and he was mentioning how good Rey is on
the defense yes okay this is a good
point so I I generally trust Fabi when
it comes to reading these players and
their weaknesses and strengths so I do
believe and also from my own experience
I played Ray many many times I feel he's
a very very good and calm Defender and
that's very important to be calm under
pressure of course it's very important
although he doesn't look really happier
at the moment but we know that he
doesn't he looks the same even in the
wedding position I don't think he ever
looks too happy exactly Rey is not the
most expressive I mean he's got that
kind of like poker face
so to speak yes
it's really it's a game to suffer yes no
jokes you're defending the central
squares all the time Anastasia let's
just jump back to the uh Marquee matchup
in our ladies section because Again
Jennifer you number one in the
tournament versus number two Arena crush
and how about that I meant mentioned
that Talia
Cervantes Talia who's on this incredible
streak of plus four loves to play the
four pawns attack and I strongly suspect
that Jennifer in her preparation for the
tournament look Italia's games and maybe
he was inspired to play the four pawns
attack herself because she's played F4
castles Knight F3 and E7 E6 and now
there's a major major diversion now D
takes E6 that was famously played by
Larry Christensen against Gary Kasparov
way back in the day but Bishop E2
is a completely different and massive
Labyrinth of opening preparation D takes
E6
is the choice of Jennifer F takes E6
Bishop E2 and basically Jennifer is
saying okay with this structure the
little bit compromised especially the
the king side Black's King could come
under pressure the pawn on D6 is
potentially weak the pawn on E6 uh
defends but it's in the way of the
bishop like exactly like for example
yeah Knight C6
castles E5 while that might be rather
suggestive to open up the bishop well
there are there are issues first of all
I can take take completely symmetrical
and white could say hey I've got the
better of the Symmetry and white also
has a very dangerous just you know go
for the pawn sacrifice type of thing
because the king is a little bit so if
you and Knight C6 pardon me castles if
you don't play for E6 what are e6e5 what
exactly are you doing let's say you a B6
because you've got it you got to do
something yeah I go King because somehow
tucking this King away is always a kind
of a good idea
and then after for example a move like
Bishop G7 once again you've got to be a
little bit cognizant that F5 is a move
you don't necessarily want to see so I'm
like this message also was not the five
ideas oh yes oh yeah you can place your
night there you will be really right and
so uh there are some challenges for
black now on the other hand now that uh
the night can come quickly to the D4
Square arena is probably thinking okay I
can go Knight to C6 uh move my knight
control the team Foursquare and I'll
have a a good game because after all
white did move her Pawn D4 D5 D takes E6
she spent a lot of Tempe and the D4
square is a great Outpost if black can
utilize it
basically I'm saying really I'm really
excited for this game uh the the
imbalance already early this early
imbalance
says this is a great fight ahead for us
exactly yes I think both players are
ready for the fight and this is really a
really nice and inspirational especially
that you're so many things can happen
and also you know they're fighting still
for the first second places and it's
really important that both kind of with
this opening code right or they tell to
each other exactly
and once again a reminder to everybody
why we've been talking about this
Marquee matchup well look at the
scoreboard Executives on the first
position and the arena
and with a victory she would score nine
Jennifer only Talia would have to win in
order to try it okay and then we'll tell
you would have to win against Jennifer
tomorrow and then there could be a
playoff yeah but a a victory almost
clinches well let's just take a quick
look at talia's game because again today
Talia is playing against begum a big big
matchup uh and it's a gruenfeld with
a7a5 Knight whoa Knight H4 I'm trying to
think I I remember Boris gal fan playing
something like this ages ago in a
candidates Knight H4 but maybe I've got
the wrong position I see that Christian
is also I'm gonna have to go to our
Oracle our all-knowing all telling all
wise
explaining everything
it's terrible
what will the coach say Knight H4 we had
this position on the board in the
morning this morning yes yes of course
and after A5 I showed her Queen to E2
8 I showed her Knight to H4 so
this is completely different she mixed
it up this is completely different of
course Knight to H4 there's an idea in
the position you want to go by four
right right because black is setting up
for the break with E5 especially it's
logical
it's a very ugly night by the way the
Knight on H4 is an extremely weak piece
and you will have to get it back into
the game very very quickly now black can
usually played the move uh E5 D5 Knight
A5 Knight before Knight to E7 are all
very playable moves and then the theory
continues after that with the move A5
was important nightwage four I don't
think it works that well because I can
go away for it this is the plan behind
the movie 45 A5 A4 expansion on the
queen side maybe even A3 followed by
knightway A5 and C5 open up the dark
Square Bishop so right now after A4 F4
which I'm expecting that is going to
happen if we see the position uh after
the A4 on on the board black can play
the move A3 A3 now if you take there's a
big problem Knight takes D4 neither is
and now you soften up uh the pawn on B2
the support of the Knight on C3 and
after Knight takes D4 I mean black is
very much close to winning okay don't
need to close to win don't take don't
take I don't like it no you don't take
on it it's not sure but what do you do
probably you go back with the knife
maybe because I just go back but then
the bishop is stuck or B2 you can play
one of knightway five followed by Knight
to C4 everything is coming with Tempo
and you will have the move C5 coming in
by the way A4 has been played in the
position so she's just messing up her
preparation she forgot it
um and right now she's not in time to
set up the bind that controlling bind
with the move F4 that's the only reason
why you would play the move the Knight
to H4 in the position and I have to say
Talia is looking good right now and she
could potentially once again with the
victory close in the gap between herself
and the leaders whoever the leaders are
going to be after this round whether
it's going to be Journey for you still
or whether it's going to be Arena Crush
Talia looks like she's uh she's kind of
happy even though she's hidden
underneath this hands uh I like I mean
her her expression to my mind is like
I'm really really alert yeah she's she's
checking it off win four games in a row
yes sir
I believe you I certainly do turning our
attention to the game of um
Sabina I think I've got my my thing
hidden a little I got some tape versus
Alice Lee I mentioned not too long ago
that one of the things I like to do is
black was to play this London put my
Pawn on H six and then took my Bishop
back it's not a fianchetto but the
bishop on H7 does a good job at
defending the king and eyeballing the C2
Pawn well Alice says you know what I
like that as well and the players have
quickly arrived at this kind of very
very standard London system and when I
see this move a uh to A3 it's basically
a kind of a red flag for me I I start
wanting to play moves like
uh C5
and B5 because once I get those two
moves in I don't think white wants to
play A4 because he already played she
already played it exactly so for for me
it's sort of like okay I'll I'll Castle
I'll as I said I'll tuck my Bishop on H7
and then I'll expand on the queen side
well keep and keep this this Sabina
versus Alice game uh and there you see
the two players Alice yesterday I wanted
to ask you about that what's a game
yesterday
she became so close to win this game
which would put her immediately on the
third place right together with Salem
and this was really important game for
the standings it's clear that she could
make more points out of the games so she
had like yesterday we started so poor
really I mean really it's not easy but
seems like she's ready to fight today
and I think it's the first time she
managed to save the bishop although the
previous times her opponents would go
Knight H4 and take this six right so now
it's the first time that she got
something to probably desired before
right Bishop will go to H7 I also like
to play this type of positions and I
think like normally should feel
comfortable right now yes it's gonna be
an interesting game I just wanted to
mention once again Sabina or has already
four points out of 11. you remember she
started really badly she did and then
she showed with her example that it's
not time to give up never give up you
have to just keep playing and try to
believe in your strengths she came once
here to the student she gave the
interview explaining that no no the the
tournament is not over she is a fighter
and she proved it by I mean she's not in
the last position anymore she has four
four points hoping to get even more
absolutely and for Alice again
celebrating her 13th birthday during the
competition but like you said she sets
some very very good positions so she
certainly could easily be in a tie for
third possibly yes yes
back to Jennifer an arena for just a
quick second we do see Knight C6 we do
have castles on the board and this is
actually again a very very important
moment
for arena she's she's kind of happy a
safe King her fair share of the center
but now she starts to look for Effective
development she has to answer a question
very Salient question what am I doing
with my light squared Bishop am I going
to be playing E5 and keeping the bishop
on the original diagonal am I going to
go B7 B6 and look to fianchetta the
position from White's point of view
Whites Whites play as I actually
remarkably easy she's going to go King h
a bishop E3 Queen D2 pile up the
pressure yes you're really easy to play
he's right you can understand the plans
and maybe on a good day when you're not
when you're moving your Bishop over to
the queen side I'll hit head out with F4
F5 again lots and lots and lots of
theory I don't mean to say that Arena's
position is bad or anything like that I
just like this is the imbalance I think
it's it's fine that remember she came
yesterday and she said maybe it's a way
to play you get a bit worse positions
then you try to win
sometimes it's funny sometimes when you
have a worse position you know what to
do other times you're like a little bit
awkward she said at the same time she
didn't realize it was so bad you know
like she says okay I didn't think it was
so bad we were talking about her game
with Nigeria yesterday he was really
really awkward and Christian back over
to you what's caught your eye so this
game between uh Christopher you who by
the way is bleaching out his moves every
single one of them at this point after
Bishop to G5 and by the way Queen to E7
was played by Ray Robson we were looking
at ideas of Bishop to E6 which we
thought is the better approach Bishop E6
Bishop G5 94 and then F5 that critical
move not easy uh to play it and allow
that pawn to stay on F6 if you don't
know the position very very well so this
is understandable that he chose to play
the move Queen to E7 a very practical
Choice take on this 6 and now Knight to
D5 has been played three times
but Christopher came with the best move
according to the engines Bishop to G5 a
novelty and he played it extremely fast
one hour in 36 minutes right now for
Christopher you so he's been blitzing
out his uh every single move don't play
the move F6 even though even F6
equalizes in the position it's quite
funny Knight to D5 Queen to G7 and now
most likely we have to go into this end
game take take I take on C7 and take on
G5 I take on A8 maybe this is something
Ray is considering right now Bishop to
F5 everything is forced pretty much 957
route to C8 Knight to D5 you take on D3
I take on D3 and then I infiltrate via
the C file I have very active pieces I
am a pawn down but I have plenty
compensation for that pawn and most
likely we're going to see a repetition
something along the lines of Knight to
E3 you run away with the Rook Knight to
C4 to attack it you run away again and
then you go back to attack it while I
try to put the Knight on a D4 so
Christopher right now maybe
understanding that that okay yes sure I
had tremendous preparation but most of
the lines especially if my opponent
knows what he's doing are going to end
up in equality that's not the only one
and you can see right now Ray is trying
to remember he's not looking at the
position he's trying to remember his
preparation Bishop to G5 he has a few
options F6 is not the only one
at that point Queen to E6 makes a lot of
sense as well Queen to E5 and to be
honest after Queen to E5 you kind of
have to go for this line Bishop to F4
Queen to C5 Bishop to E3 Queen to E5 and
Bishop to F oh really so unless you want
to be much worse as white which I don't
think
um Christopher you is trying to be so
perhaps after Queen to C5 Rook to E1 but
I think there's something of the root oh
yes Rook to E8 that's problematic Rook
to E8 if we exchange any pieces in the
position you're going to be in deep
danger as uh White so this one it says
that black is close to winning in the
position you have to be very careful you
need to spend to keep your pieces for
the attack right yes yes and I think you
have to just go Bishop E3 Bishop before
and make a draw at that point
um you have to take it again it's a mini
gamble by Christopher you he probably
didn't have enough time to prepare this
game and he decided to look in his
archives of gambits and he came up with
this idea putting something yeah
uh speaking of archives and gambits I
don't even know what to describe is
going on between Sam Sevilla and Hans
Neiman because I just have never seen a
position of like 15 players have
achieved and in fact it looks kind of
hilarious like somebody you took uh you
gave a box of chess pieces to a
six-year-old and said you know just try
to play this position put some pieces on
the board and I'm looking at this Pawn
on G2 and I'm thinking to myself how did
it get there and then I saw this Knight
on G5 and I said oh of course I'm going
to play Knight F7 check Fork the king
fork The Rook completely let me forget
it Bishops can come backwards what a
mess exactly explain this one yeah
good luck
I mean I'll explain it to you Hans knows
exactly what he's doing Sam Seville
doesn't and he's trying to figure out
the best moves over the board uh wow
Theory ended up long time ago okay
Bishop to F4 and Rook to C8 was in fact
uh the first move that is not uh part of
theoretical knowledge this was played
between urquidal and Carlson in 2021 and
that was played with the move Bishop to
B3 getting out of charge of this Knight
takes C6 attack Rook to C8 was new G3
was played quite quickly also by our
friend Sam Savion
and let's see where did he think for a
very long time after F3 take take Rook
to G1 Knight to F6 okay he's been
thinking for a very long time after
Knight to F6 so it seems like both of
these players were actually aware of
this particular line up to this point
this move Knight to F6 which by the way
is the best move according to the
engines we're expecting Rook takes G2 is
H6 a potential move here that's a crazy
move there's six that's a move as well
so I I guess I have to get out of Dodge
and we take the pawn you take it now I
can even take really
wow just take like this wow
I mean it's not what I will exactly I'm
like really unexpected I mean I think
like six or seven or eight moves ago
everything's unexpected remember what he
had a clear shot of Sam uh Savion uh
again he's having a maybe his most
outstanding uh uh U.S Championship he's
undefeated
yeah
and two victories sorry Christian he had
a good one last year he went into the
playoffs last yes
so that was an outstanding success he's
just confirming what he did last year
yes he's definitely one of the best
players here yeah and uh actually now
they have only one point distance
between
um seven hunts you see six and a half
points for seven five and a half for
hands so Hans probably is looking
forward to find some sharp positions
where he will get some chances and he
got it yes he plays really fast I mean
it's lately this is how he plays in the
opening really fast I did I I gotta ask
how do the engines evaluate it Christian
and 0.0 yeah yeah of course of course of
course okay let's try it a different one
what do the engines consider the best
moves just Rook takes G2 and then I'm
assuming black plays Bishop C5 Bishop C5
yes very good okay very good I got that
one I got one I got one yeah the engines
yes sir and they know everything and
then and then and now this is something
I take C4 oh that was I was very
reluctant to give up the dark side
ambition I know yeah it doesn't feel
very natural right right but at the same
time you're getting a lot of activities
so for example Bishop to D4 you can go
Knight to eat to hunt this bishop down
and uh where do you put the bishop by
the way uh-huh
but then I go here you go Bishop here I
take okay and then I go no I don't go
there I give you a check okay it's a
mess
I was I was looking for something more
more obvious than it's a mess I had a
mess already 10 moons ago
this is not practical at all for a while
because you're a pawn down and you don't
actually see where the compensation lies
right right other than the activities
it's the craziest position which Sam
seventh uh had the during all these
rounds I mean normally he is like very
very solid right right and I think
constantly it's got the position which
is like more for his style than seven
yes maybe he feels better here than Sam
at this moment if if we speak about the
psychological point of view well also uh
Anastasia boldly stating the obvious
look at the difference in the class yes
exactly yes it's like almost times I I
well I'm saying Hans has gained time so
not only are we deeply in hans's
preparation Sam's figuring it out at the
board and Hans saying okay come on you
got to catch up with me I know the next
three six seven eight moves oh yes and
you don't it and you don't that's
exactly what he's saying you don't know
what I what I've got prepped for you and
and that whole Bishop takes F6 that I I
think I'm giving up the advantage when I
do things I I can go with Rook takes G2
I just I'm so reluctant to play Bishop
takes F6 if that's my best move I'm not
happy with the outcome of the opening
like just to understand like please I'm
with you 100 honestly can they take on
me four no I don't think so well the the
issue here is is yeah you know you you
instantly play the move rookie eight
because you have no choice you're gonna
have to play F2 F3 in this case and now
should I defend G7 should I
um
take on H5 the problem from White's
point of view is it's incredibly
desirable to play the moved castles yes
but uh so we'll try the same as Chris
the software won't allow us to Castle I
mean this bishop on B3 is a massive
irritant uh to White's development and
here again whether I should defend G7 or
whether I should go Rook takes H5 and
continue uh yeah I have some issues also
on the first rank but you know like it's
somehow a kind of mutually assured
destruction going on yes
I don't know I don't know
okay so we got one right in a very very
chaotic position but what an important
game this is for Sam sevion that came
into the show saying family played a
great tournament last two rounds these
Championship rounds you can spoil your
event or make it one to remember if he
wins now for example he has his chances
even for the first place this is really
really important yes so yeah and you
know he's thinking about it you know I
mean he's only one point behind Fabiano
if he wins this one and he has white
pieces against a player that is only on
50 right so you're going to try to put
as much pressure as possible I'm not
sure if he's very happy with the outcome
of this opening obviously Hans seems to
be very well versed in this line he has
ideas of his own once again the theory
ended five moves ago so Han still knows
exactly what he's doing maybe this move
Rook to G2 which is a bit it's a very
natural move of course so you probably
should know how to respond to it we're
going to have to wait and see Hans is
probably trying to recall his
preparation and let's wait and see
whether he's going to find the best
moves in the position or maybe an equal
pretending that he knows everything you
know it also happens you know sometimes
you're gambling in a way you are trying
to kind of pretend that you know
everything no no but he played the best
moves after this point yeah
sometimes it happens with one hour and
30 minutes I'm not sure okay and you've
got our Marquee matchup game going on in
the ladies section what developments
have taken place Christian uh well let's
take a look I think we left it after
this move Bishop to E2 Knight C6 Main
Line uh it seems like uh Irina was still
within her preparation castle and now a
B6 still the main line but Irina thought
for a very long time now it makes a lot
of sense you're trying to get the bishop
to B7 put as much pressure on uh the
pawn on e4 and at some point maybe maybe
even have ideas of playing the move D5
in the future okay a very intriguing
position how are you going to develop
your pieces as white
King H1 King to H1 sure let's go Bishop
B7 F5 oh immediately F5 really yeah
I'm gonna I mean yes sir
rexing will we love it
this is the Grand Prix attack I'll take
it nice page four you that's fine I
learned the lesson probably yeah D4
Knight F5
um
where's your attack I don't know do I
have an attack no you're lost lost
you're completely lost oh no actually
yeah yeah
sir yes this is
first and then go crazy I can teach you
as well yes no problem I gotta sign up
for your course as soon as I get out of
Studio
once you land here I have all sorts of
ideas of Discovery attacks because the
queen is on D1 and I'm attacking to
exchange the Queens if I manage to
exchange the Queens you are a bit
overextended with these spawns on uh F4
and E4 and you also have to worry about
this monster on G7 once diagonal opens
up I'm going to have a lot of targets on
that diagonal so this one very
interesting game but I have to say if
Irina wants to win this one and surpass
Johnny for you she got the perfect
position to do so all right very
balanced remains extremely balanced uh
turning our attention to the game
between Sam Shanklin and Fabiano for a
moment because again this is also our
tournament leader game Anastasia we saw
the movie E7 E6 by Fabi I mean I think a
lot of people would have played Bishop
G7 you know rather instantly I would
have definitely been considering Knight
B6 he went for E7 E6 uh and my database
stopped by the way like it just like
said that's a novel move I I find it
hard to believe that's a novelty because
after Knight E5 Bishop D7 white wins the
two Bishops but it's not so cut and dry
black has a great great outpost on the
D4 Square for the night so I wouldn't
imagine that White's advantage of the
two Bishops is so uh overwhelming that
this hasn't been tried before only that
in our database we we don't have games
from B7 B6 castles rook d8 and we're up
to date with the play essentially Fabi
is ready to play Knight D4 okay we can
trade queens and I'm looking at this
point
by the way this is another one of those
reasons why players love to see and
Shadow the Bishops if you look at that
Bishop on G7 you go oh you're charming
you're just such a beautiful Bishop you
protect my king but also you're
eyeballing the B2 Pawn so you're doing a
double duty offensive and defensive work
by this great Bishop on G7 once Fabi
gave up this bishop Bishop C3 there was
a famous game when he decided to get rid
of this fantastic Vision but it was for
the reason I remember to
explanation export exclamation yeah
this move so yeah I've always thought
about that you know like these um
Sicilian dragons yes you got this Dragon
bishop and in my mind I have this image
of the Dragon beat breathing fire and
then the people give up the bishop wow
what are you doing idiot everybody teach
you about Dragon Bishops uh what's going
on in the Pappy game well actually there
was a big opportunity uh move ago oh
check this out so instead of Castle
which is very natural and he taught
quite a long time for this move Knight
takes D5 was an option okay before B4
take advantage of this pin right so if
you cannot take with the Knight because
you lose the queen so you have to find
the compensation because I am taking
your point taking part so you have to go
for Rook to ye now this creates an
immediate threat if you take on C5
really easy to check nice Knight to D4
yeah right you can follow this so you
have to defend against that E3 most
likely instead of taking on C5
reinforcing the threat of taking on C5
okay and then we see see these type of
situations Rook 88 you take Knight to E5
take Knight takes D3 King to F1 you
cannot go to E2 because yeah with a
check so you have to go to F1 take C6
and this position is very difficult to
assess most likely it's going to be very
close to equality at the same time black
does have the two Bishops and quite a
powerful Pawn on C6 right so you have to
be uh quite cognizant of that now we see
a completely different situation right
now Castle Rook to d8 Rook to D1
the queen is defended so you don't have
any ideas of B4 anymore because if you
take take instead of Rook to D1 if you
take take and B4 I can just simply take
with an item B4 right absolutely no
problems for black Rook fd1
and as you mentioned the answer you see
this move Knight to D4 you see a
beautiful Outpost if you try to kick the
Knight away with E3 then D3 is going to
become weak I like black in the position
I think Fabiano caruana has probably
equalized uh this game and doesn't have
any problems out of the opening against
the 2018 Champion Samsung
wow and I remember that Championship
it's I I it's still a kind of a funny
moment when uh Bobby was complaining
yeah after the tournament you know I was
tied for first with three rounds to go
yes I scored two and a half out of three
and I said you know mail me my first
place check you know or did I tie for
first place no you got second because
your rival got three out of three so I'm
Shanklin went on a last uh minute tear
uh that was a very intriguing line that
you showed with before
because in in that line with E3 and good
night D4 I mean I don't even have to
trade Queens I would even just kind of
just sit there and consider okay what if
I just dropped back with the queen for
just a moment I mean but now for the
moment I'm upon up right let's try to do
you are a pawn up I have ideas of Queen
F5 life maybe take on C5 and Rook to B8
that's an option as well
maybe take on C5 and Rook to B8 and then
as an option there's a rugby team where
do you put uh the desirable Queen C2
does run into
Rook B2 that's sometimes D4 also maybe
sometimes maybe you can take on D5 but
um
D3 yeah I'm living a very uh very
dangerous life there uh okay maybe it
means Queen A3 Queen E3 Queen
B5 ideas also Queen B5 ideas
okay this isn't but now I can take on C5
as well and you cannot take with the
Rook because of Bishop f8 right that is
true oh
that that is very very true yeah um okay
I'm not getting so you probably have to
trade the Queens
all moves written in here
you think so yes I think you were
walking the same to go for this line
absolutely well we've come to that point
in the show Anastasia where we want to
again uh welcome our viewers thank you
all for watching and also invite them to
join our discussion yes exactly uh post
some questions to Anastasia Christian or
myself how do they do it on the social
yes so we have first of all everybody
has to follow our social media
absolutely if you have Twitter
subscriptions always welcome absolutely
Saint Louis chess club is your way to
get to social media in Instagram Twitter
and also don't forget to check you to
follow YouTube channel as well we have
many many nice videos and interviews
there so if you want to ask the question
the commentators you can use stack U.S
chess Champs or mention some blues chess
club as well we have a question we do
good and this one is from Sam films
I would love a hot take from Yasser on
the Amman Lawrence chess boxing match
but this is incredible well thank you
very much for Sam film so the hot take
is Aman Hamilton of the chess bras is
going up against the pugilist Lawrence
and uh they're going to play they're
going to have a chess boxing duel and
what that is it's a hybrid boxing match
you play some good chess moves then you
get up and then you box your opponent so
whoever checkmates or knocks out that's
it the the duel is over and
I have to confess I've never gone to a
chess boxing me too but there is so much
at stake
your health your head everything
everything
I I think it will be a lot of fun I just
don't want anybody get hurt this is for
sure and we could see all these videos
of Florence preparation pushing Magnus
really is that what it's a yeah
he's got the Rocky music going on
everything I think Christian may also
give some information I'm sure he's
going closely are you coming to L.A to
watch this match I'm not 100 sure
is it LA or Vegas
in Los Angeles in Los Angeles okay yes
December 11th so shout out to uh Mogul
moves I think that's the organization
organizing the match and uh yeah that
should be a good one I don't know who do
you guys have or in that hey look you
know I I'm with chest bras I have a I
have an affinity there uh you know I
gotta I gotta I'm not going to make my
take on this one I'll be thinking about
it yes
would you like to take part in such
events everybody knows about your great
shape exactly
man I've done some uh some some
kickboxing for a few years so I think I
can take pretty much anybody in the
Chess World
that's a challenge there it is uh
Christian uh open open challenge yes yes
uh crazily enough Christian you you had
this game of Ray Robson earlier and you
were calling exactly this line yeah
spoilers spoiler alert yeah and uh he's
going for it he's going for it he's
going for it and right now he has the
option of once again F takes G5 Knight
eight Bishop F5 that's the line we've
seen yes or even Rook to F7 look to F7
you can take on F6 first or you can take
on A8 take on G5 and now the question is
how do you get the night out exactly
because I am going B6 Bishop B7 and I
capture the Knight if you don't okay do
something fast so you have to Target my
knight on D6 with a move Rook to D1
again I'm looking at the position from a
practical perspective I don't think uh
Ray Robinson is going to allow these
ideas Rook to D1 and Target Knight on D6
I think he will be looking for something
a bit more forced in the position and
that is taking on a G5 and Bishop to F5
he's down an hour on his clock right big
five minutes or so
Christopher's five minutes wow
haven't had this in his preparation what
preparation yes yes yes she would
already win this game right right right
oh my goodness but I had a question for
you Christian because uh that line that
you showed had a flaw yes if you take
and I take and you went Bishop F5 and I
went Knight C7 and you went Rook C8 I
did I don't move the night I'll take
your Bishop okay and I take with the
Knight and well I've got a check that's
okay how do you just go King UPS yes and
oh my God and then actually night is
what I was you wanted to go to D4 I know
I know
five is nicely protecting that's where
it certainly is actually you were worse
after yeah well if I have to do that
you're absolutely right oh my goodness
yeah it's pretty much forced to be
honest because if you try to go Knight
B5 and then say that I'm going to take
on D6 and then on D3 it's not working I
take on D3 no no or I can do that also
yes I was thinking of taking on D3 and
taking on C2 with Eric also good point
you're you're still coming out maybe I'm
on the better side yes I wouldn't argue
I won't argue that point at all well
from Ray's point of view if if I'm down
an hour on the clock I want to play the
most forcing yeah line I can so in that
case taking on G5 and Bishop F5
everything with tempo right yes at the
end of this whole ordeal you are a pawn
down but you're so active I don't think
white has a great way to do anything in
the position
this is this is the line oops excuse me
with Rook C8 that you had showed Knight
D5 Bishop takes and Rook C2 and you're
getting great uh compensation yes yes
with such active Rook okay to be honest
let's try to actually capture by the way
by the way that takes on G5 yes
I got a feeling we called this whole
game already we might have yeah
like what
uh Rook C2 yes and continue so let's try
to find a way to capture the pawn maybe
Rook D2
well you mean D3 Rook D2
or Rook to B1 I think you want to play
root B right okay
then what do you play actually I mean if
you go night before I go A5 and I
capture the pawn
yeah
this is easy enough yeah yeah there's
there's no way you win this one or maybe
like a fork also doesn't work right
something like that or maybe some tricks
with Knight C7 no
there are no tricks not looking like
there's anything I'm not I'm just simply
not keeping the pawn I mean the only
thing I can imagine is well something of
this nature where oh where you know I if
I could get into E2 and Rook C1 maybe
maybe
five I exchange everything
yeah exchange everything yeah you get
the root of D7 to defend everything on
the seventh Rank and yeah I will call it
a day very soon very soon yeah yeah I
agree wholeheartedly okay well once
again let's go back to our uh by the way
thank you for the question about the
chess box yes
a real hybrid I want to say B7 B6 in our
Marquee matchup uh the two moves that we
expect white to play Bishop E3 for
Jennifer and or King H1 or maybe h2h3
with the intention of Bishop E3 and just
get the development and see what the
middle game is going to bring again
um out of the three games these two
ladies tested in the past Jennifer with
the two and a half yes again Anastasia
for me I would not have guessed that I
would have lost a serious wager yes
exactly but but I really
like Marina yesterday she said that it's
not really bothers her I asked her if it
affects somehow her mood before this
really important match to have a bad
opponent yes it's really hard sometimes
right right now we can see on the
screens they score like two wins for
Jennifer sometimes you really don't like
this type of situation precisely right
she was so optimistic she said well if
you have this opportunity to fight for
the first place and you have to play
this game it's already great like I have
my chances actually to remove the
obstacle remove the obstacle yes a
fantastic phrase actually so
motivational for all chess players
around the world because we don't know
how to deal with these situations and I
think this was really right or attitude
like I'm not hiding from it yes I have a
bad score but I'm the one who can
improve it right and she gave us an
example her long-term rival with Anna
satonski you remember they played like
30 games and uh before and she was not
doing so well well Arena crash and later
she managed to change the score on her
favorite and maybe even on her favor yes
yeah wow whoa whoa whoa whoa what
happened Jennifer played a move that's
simply bad I mean there's no way to move
Knight F3 to E1 even came into my mind
because the Knight on F3 was uh
desperately needed to protect against
Knight to D4 if I'm black I'm playing
Knight to D4 not even asking questions
as to why you played that move Knight on
D4 the bishop will come to B7 and Arena
will have simply the advantage
um
I mean I understand that Jennifer's
thinking that the bishop will
neutralize its counterpart on F3 but
you're wasting time and you really need
to get your pieces out Bishop E3 King H1
and it's the first time I see you so
shocked yesterday
like like okay I mean I understand
blunders you know you make the wrong
capture at the wrong time or you play
the a combination out of turns but this
is just a strategic question why why
would you play 91 well Anastasia I mean
was that in your no no it was not on my
candidates move definitely I don't know
maybe she wants to put her Knight on C2
later and then you wait to see two what
is the plan uh Bishop to E3 well again
if I'm in uh Arena yeah I'm in Arena
shoes I'm saying thank you very much I I
appreciate your retreat uh I'll take up
uh so Bishop for example Bishop E3 okay
and I take a take and take it this is
what I was trying to understand I mean
you're fine to take the bishop only two
right and end up with two nice Bishops
in this position I very reluctantly
accepted the advantage yes I I exactly
so uh Anastasia we've come to that point
in our show where we have to check in on
our good friends at qbt
it's open again
what's what's the special so we have
button up dress short let's check it out
it's with long sleeves it's very nice
yes and yeah well I also have one it's
really great so look at your best in
this
with the Champs button up dressed short
with long sleeves in men's and women's
sizes this comfortable button up
features and embroidered just logo
beautiful
you did it and those are the Saint
Lucia's Club logo on the back which is
also Imports and shop online right now
at Q Boutique and by the way I've seen
many players who wear this this short
which is really nice yeah absolutely
yeah the model looks really really good
and we'll see you all on the other side
of our brain
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at St louisjessclub.org
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the World Chess Hall of Fame in St Louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the World
Chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and welcome back everyone it's round 12
of us chess championships and we can see
the standings on our screens Jennifer
you keeps living with eight points and
Arena crashes following her with seven
and a half points and today they play
against each other huge game yes and
Tyler Cervantes is on the third position
when she plays today against beg him
with her Donovan who is on the fifth
place right now another huge game yes
very great battles going on and the
weapon section and in the open section
Fabiano caruana is on the lead right now
he has seven and a half points Ray
Robson plays against Christopher you
today he has seven poets and he is also
looking forward to improve his position
right linear Dominguez with six and a
half points as well as Sam Sabian also
with six and a half they share the third
place that that matchup between Fabi and
Sam Shanklin very very important but
let's jump right into it as we've got
this game between a Jennifer an arena
and uh I did not like well as we went on
break I did not like the retreat that
Jennifer played we start to understand
her ideas she played Knight F3 to E1
Bishop B7 Bishop D3 Knight D4 just you
know taking up residence in the middle
of the board now Jennifer definitely did
not and she did not take on D4 she
didn't want to walk into this very
um
I want to say uh problematic a discovery
of Knight takes E4 the bishop on G7
would be uncovered and she instead she
just said look I'm going to play around
the night I'm going to put the bishop on
D3 I'll protect the pawn on e4 so long
as I have this situation I'm happy I
want to invite the move D5 like please
please please play D5 so that I would
take take and then with the move E5 I've
got this Pawn chain that shuts down the
bishop I see and if I continue like with
Knight E4 just uh
I mean the game does continue it's not
the end of the game it's just that from
gender first perspective she's saying
okay I'm fighting for an advantage or
I'd like to believe I'm fighting for an
advantage because the bishop at least is
not radiant okay so that's what she says
Bishop to D3 and Arena says look I don't
care about your problems I've just
connected my Rooks I've completed my
development my Bishop's looking good
I've got more than my fair share of the
center
and my king is safe and Jennifer says
you know what you're right unite is
really looking good so even though she's
she's lost a little bit of Tempe she's
hoping that she could and do induce her
opponent to well even here D5 and D4
starts to be problematic she's hoping to
get a situation where where the knights
just simply come off
and she's happy I'm for me my problem as
white is I'm thinking that black will
want to maintain her Knight on the D4
square with a move like Knight H5 and
I'm not one of those who are inclined to
play G4 in such positions
you're like really dangerous opening up
my king and to maintain the the Knight
on D4 also something to think about E5
but uh Christian Jump Right In on uh I
see you've got that chaotic position Sam
said beyond Behind you uh what's going
on lots of things are actually happening
in a lot of games and we will be
discussing that in just a second let's
take a look at what happened in this
game between Sam Savion and Neiman so
anyone did play the move Bishop to C5
which we thought was the best movie in
the position and you also recommended it
Yasser quite quickly it makes a lot of
sense you're putting as much pressure
and you're trying to maintain the
initiative in the position now white has
a couple of options Knight tweet was the
move that we were looking at Bishop
takes F6 is another one
check this move out by Sam seven you
know D1 look at this he just played them
we did not even consider it no no how to
consider this movement now you take on
the one and Knight to E6 this is the key
right because otherwise you're just
losing a rookie or an exchange King E7
Knight takes C5 Bishop takes H5
everything is pretty much forced at this
point take on F7 Bishop to F7 I'm going
to cover that as well and this is the
position that it seems were headed
towards okay how do we assess it there's
an exchange for black I understand you
have a lot of weaknesses and I can
immediately take one of the pawns with
the move Knight to B7 you still have to
worry about the pawn on A7 it's an
interesting uh position and we're on to
a collusion course right now take take I
take on A7 two pawns for the exchange
but you still have some weaknesses on
the queen side and if I manage to
capture this Pawn on H2 and then start
going down the board with this H Pawn
maybe I even have the opportunity to be
better as black so Hans Neiman a golden
opportunity perhaps to win this game
against Sam sevignon still a very
complex battle even in this position but
definitely it seems like black is in the
lead and let's take a look at what's
happening Wow versus uh Fabiano caruana
take a look at that one as well Hans
definitely thinking looking at his
opponent trying to understand what Sam
Seville has calculated in that
particular line and what do we have in
this position take a look
after H6 makes a lot of sense you're
taking away this bishop to G5 which was
making life uncomfortable for The Rook
on d8 makes a lot of sense to play the
move H6 King to F1 was played by Sam
Shanklin now what's the idea behind this
King to F1 in a lot of lines we were
seeing ideas of Knight to D4 right
Knight to D4 exchanged the queens and
then always at some point the spawn on
E2 was hanging so this is what king to
F1 is uh getting ready for ideas of
Knight to D4 try to meet those with
Queen D7 and not have to worry about the
pawn on E2 after that okay and F5 was
Fabiano's response you put the King on
the F5 I'm going to open the F5 and I'm
going to try to get an attack going I
like this move F5 by Fabiano
and right now the engine is saying this
takes and B4 B4 yeah in the position
take on B4 take on D7 take on D7 take on
B4 everything is forced
and then just play for initiative we do
have opposite color Bishops I am going
to get one of your pawns most likely I'm
going to close down the bishop D4
followed by E3 you still have to worry
about the weakness on a D5 and then I'm
just going to try to Corral around this
Pawn on D5 Rook to C1 Rook to C8 Rook to
C6 the other rook and try to gain an
advantage based on that how do we assess
uh this position guys do we think that
white has enough compensation for just
equality enough compensation for maybe
even a slight advantage in this one by
the way it's not clear whether he's
going to play like this and white to be
honest has and he's not he just played
the move A3 we have the move A3 in the
position preparing the move B4 yes later
on in line take and then go before and
not give up the pawn makes a lot of
sense
two Bishops you do uh seem a bit
overextended on the king side I'm
starting to like White's position right
now what about the four move still
yes
and I'm going to take that pawn yes so
now I can take probably with the
Knights of course that's the keys yeah
you cannot you're actually just losing
yes I'll lose the pump like this yes you
will take on D5
but G5 go ahead yeah
well you now you go Bishop to D Ford
let's go yes sir I like this idea okay
well do you mean not not now I'm Gonna
Leave You with the rest the rest is easy
come on let's let's see what you have uh
actually I don't have that not that much
you know it seems like this attack is
not working so well well I wanted to do
the F7 yes you really are trying to
check me I mean this night only four is
like really showing calm
calm but we try no problem
we tried very hard but it's important to
understand let's say that sometimes this
kind of side attacks they're simply not
working that's true of it so and it
makes sense because white didn't
actually make any ugly moves in the
position right yeah why just develop
their pieces there's absolutely no
premise for why he should be falling
under a tremendous attack right so you
have to get ready for that you have to
go G5 maybe but G5 comes at the cost
you're overextending as well an
interesting position in this one let's
see what Fabiano caruana is going to
come with as a plan in the position yes
well let's just remind everybody Ray
Robson and Chris Christopher you came
unbelievably well prepared he went bang
bang I mean he played like 20 moves and
he gained five minutes on his clock I
mean what to say that game is really
really looks like it's going for a draw
I just just doesn't seem like either
player has a chance yes which opens up a
door you know okay uh half a point going
into the game
fobby's head as as a lead should Fabi
win that guarantees him at least uh a
tie for first depending on what happens
between Savion and Lanier he could
potentially win the game win the
tournament I apologize with a win today
but again uh nothing terribly amiss in
Sam shanklin's position and I'm turning
our attention to a game of Talia and I
really like her position I'll come back
to me explain why but first Christian
you have a guest in studio thank you yes
sir yes we are here with Alex careforth
Financial Analyst at Edward Jones and a
good friend here in St Louis Alex
welcome to the show thank you Christian
you're also a trustee of the U.S trust
fund tell us a bit about that and what's
the mission of the farm I mean for
several decades the U.S chess trust has
been a
sponsor of Scholastic programs across
the country very excited to have the
opportunity to be added as a trustee and
continue to see the something that I'm
passionate about be able to be put into
action through the trust and most
recently we're involved in a new library
project where we're seeing different
types of boards and tournaments
happening in libraries across the
country so it's been a good Endeavor
really enjoy it that's definitely a cool
mission that you guys have at the trust
also you are a founder of the corporate
chest lick I know that we have the
Collegiate chess League you guys have
the corporate trust League tell us a bit
about that and the vision behind that I
mean the the whole idea of the St Louis
corporate chess League was to find a way
where different companies could come and
have cross-industry ideas sharing have
an opportunity to network build
friendships
across something that we all really
enjoy which was playing chess and so
when I had talked with the team here at
the St Louis chess club of course they
go well above and beyond to make this
this little idea an amazing reality I
think we have seven teams now as you can
see on the dates there The Fall season
has just kicked off I will say there
seems to be a correlation Christian
between Financial folks and chess Edward
Jones has won six of the last seven
seasons and so I'm pretty proud about
that and we need some some new talents
to come in someone come and take this
champion of Edward Jones right the
captain yeah so it's been a real team
look at this uh this semester Captain
hey we're we're going to compete again
we always have our Arch Rivals over at
Enterprise who are ready to to jump on
and uh and take it to us but I think the
team's going to do pretty well again
hopefully get to the the final four and
we also have this cool thing the
strategy across the board you're
involved with that as well what's the
plan for this year the the vision of
strategy across the board is the St
Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame and the amazing things that
we're doing throughout the entire
Metropolitan St Louis area some 80 000
students throughout Metro St Louis are
being taught mentored given
opportunities to enjoy this game and
seeing it translate to excelling in the
classrooms different studies that we've
done that show a correlation there and
so a lot of the proceeds of this Gala
will help go and continue to support the
Scholastic program and then also the
World Chess Hall of Fame so having the
different composer series music series
of course the amazing art exhibitions
that go on throughout the year is also
being supported through the gala and
it's just a lot of fun to be able to
plan and be a part of chess boards that
you've never seen before very exotic
ways that you can actually have an
opportunity to bid on those and some
amazing keynote speakers and and
different chess folks that you would
you'd love to meet so come to the gala
December 3rd it's awesome no absolutely
it's a lot of fun we usually go there I
think the after party we have some
videos on YouTube with Yasser dancing
Alejandro dancing and things of that
nature it's a lot of fun guys any
questions for uh Alex absolutely first
of all uh thank you Alex for all you've
done and congratulations to being a
chess trustee U.S chess trust I think
when I think of the U.S chest trust I
think of the this um this separate body
from the USCF that supports the chess
and schools program that's Dwayne Barber
and all of these uh national
championships and uh you guys just
impact So Many Lives I mean it's
extraordinary talk about the history and
how it is how the U.S chest stress has
evolved because what you've been doing
it wasn't around or maybe it was it just
wasn't it was kind of dormant but it
wasn't around in my age
I mean so another aspect that I can see
I mean is is exhibited by the players
that you see on the screen today many of
which have been recipients of the
Samford Fellowship exactly and receiving
funding to continue their their chess
careers and it had a lot of relationship
historically with the United States
Chess Federation now has has grown into
its own entity but those are some of the
things that will be the legacy of the
United States Chess trust as well as
being the voting members of who gets
into the Chess Hall of Fame boats in the
United States and the World Chess Hall
of Fame so a lot of Rich history and and
folks that I feel like I get the
opportunity to work with who I've I've
looked up to or maybe you haven't heard
of but have had massive influences on
United States Chess overall well again
the Samford because you mentioned a big
shout out to Al Lawrence the managing
director of the U.S Chester and
everything that he does but the Sanford
Fellowship these are huge grants that
allow the players to really hone their
game and I think in this event
the Samford has sponsored over the
history 11 of the 14 players in the open
wow and Alice Lee for example today is a
Samford fellow I'd talk about the
leadership that's going on there with
the Sanford fellow
Grant Awards sure well it's it's really
inspiring that chess can reach so many
different people and the desire for
someone to want to to give a donation
and perpetuity right to continue to see
um the opportunity for for chess careers
launched has has like you said produced
numerous Champions some of our
up-and-coming prodigies in the United
States and and allowing them to continue
to travel to different tournaments be
able to receive the coaching and
mentoring that that is necessary to
compete at a high level and so that that
type of donation and
um and vision For Those Behind the
Samford is is really special for the
United States
thank you so much again Alex for
everything you do that the chest trust
does and again a very big shout out to
Al Lawrence uh everybody's favorite uh
chess supporter thank you thank you
thank you for being on the show again uh
I want to just take our attention
is he not the youngest looking 65 year
old in the world I mean he's just
amazing isn't it are you joking
no he's coming down to beat me up happy
birthday happy birthday
yeah I mean seriously without kite we
would not be on air he does so much he's
he he's great
um I just want to turn our attention to
the Jennifer uh versus Arena match
because seriously I I like what arena
did the Knight D7 move but you know we
were talking about development and
effective development yes I see the move
Rook B1
and I go well where do you go like what
do you mean
I mean the rook's better on B1 than A1
because it does defend the B2 Pawn but
it's not what you would really describe
as effective like in my mind you know
you're playing Queen D2
or D1 or E1 or maybe you go Rook to F2
and you put your Rook on so I don't see
this move as benefiting uh White NOW
Arena played the move Rook F7 I got no
problems with that move I think that's a
decent move and and I I can really
understand why she wants to double her
Rooks but another move I'd really want
to consider is for example D5
immediately okay let's check yeah so
what's going on here after D5 so if you
take right okay okay we can see that
after I take uh well there are some
issues uh but you do have an escape
valve you can you can capture and
capture and maybe the worst has passed
so you can maybe explain that now it was
a threat you cannot just take on D5 yes
after e takes D5 you cannot take because
Knight C2 and Rook history is coming
here yeah Queen E3 exactly yeah exactly
uh so you can see that that's a
possibility another possibility is the
Knight on D7 if you ever take
I see the Knight is going to go to C5 so
I start to think well maybe I can play
E5 okay with the idea that I want to
take and put my other Knight on the E5
square right so from
Arena's perspective she starts to think
I have this break I have this I have
this right and crazily enough C5 G5 it's
another one of those you know uh
uh the breaks that you've got to
consider finally she did play the move
Rook F7 which
prepares everything yeah and just brings
The Rook into the game so for me the
trend is an Arena's favor uh at this
moment because I just don't like the
sequence that Jennifer's come up with
exactly at this moment also I just
wanted to go to the game of Talia who as
we said is coming into the show she's
been on a tear and oh she's played the
move h786 and I wanted to say that I
really really liked talia's position a
lot I see uh
um not a complete development I want to
say but I see a very good development
for black this bishop looks really good
this bishop looks really good the
knights look really good the Rooks only
the queen
I really want to play the move C5 like
many grunfell players would like to play
when I play the move C5 I open up the
diagonal so so
let's get the Knight out of the way uh
threaten something like Bishop Bishop D3
okay sometimes
yeah it might might be but knight uh
before if you play I don't know Rook D1
just the side step you know just a
little bit the bishop to coming to D3
now we understand C5 comes and if we
ever get a position pardon me let me
just put this on the board like this you
go wow everything's opened up nice also
A3 excuse me bacon what are your pieces
doing on A1 and C1 Italia played the
move H7 H6 okay I understand you want to
give yourself a look but sometimes this
kind of opportunity you know doesn't
knock all all day long you know everyone
can prevent them exactly just a little
bit so I like to earlier's position I
think there was a more effective way of
play than H7 H6 Christian over to you
and what have you been looking at so
I've been looking at the open section
and what's happening in that one in the
critical matches let's take a look so
this is the Fabiano game uh Sam Shanklin
versus Fabiano caruana and actually uh
after this move A3 B4 came on the board
so Fabiano immediately responded with
the move Knight to D4 offering the queen
trade Queen D7 Rook D7 95 take on D5 and
now it's all about the pressure on this
Pawn D5 against the activity of black
species a black has very active Knight
witch Pawn G7 is a beautiful piece the
route coming to E8 potentially putting a
lot of pressure on the e-file as well on
the other hand white has some ideas on
the queen side specifically related
against the pawn structure B4 had to be
played Knight to B3 take on C5 don't
take on C1 because after C6 in fact this
position is pretty bad for a black that
is Rook to D6 or Rook to C7 Rook to D6 I
can go Bishop to B4 first get my change
back you still have a lot of weaknesses
in the position you're going to be a
pawn down that's just simply going to be
a losing end game you cannot do that you
cannot look at the exchange you have to
take on C5 Rook to B1 this is the
position we have currently on the board
big moment right now how is black going
to respond to this situation if you go
C4 the problem is after Bishop to B4 you
might be in trouble the D file opens up
I have Bishop to D5 coming after that
with the support of The Rook on D1 this
is not looking good it's not stable for
a black Black's position is not stable
so if you do take on D2 which makes a
lot of sense right I'm looking at the
position I see as white I have control
over the B file yes I have a nice
pressure on the spawn on D5 I have a
nice pressure on the pawn on C5 after
the move Rook to C2 coming I'm seeing
the position as clearly better for white
I have all the trumps in the position
this is not looking good so you have to
find something else as black the only
other candidate move that I can see
after the move Rook to B1 is the move
Rook to B8 with 92 idea yes with of
course in this small trick yeah that's a
big one of course yes very nice trick so
Rook to B1 Rook to B8 now you have to uh
worry about that if you go H4 Knight
takes the two finishes the game of
course you can give you one maybe King
E1 is a move yes King E1 is definitely a
move but now it seems that black gets
the king to E6 in time and then manages
to double up on the B file that's going
to secure uh his position and most
likely black history going to be fine
but what you can do is play this move
that's very true an interesting one
right yeah still putting a lot of
pressure on the night you have to do
something about that C4 doesn't work
because you have problems on the D file
you have to take on B4 okay take on B4
take on B3 you gotta play A5 absolutely
and now I have to lock this bishop out
at least not allow it to go to C3
because that's going to create some
problems you can have some problems here
let's go to with D4 right okay Bishop to
f8 okay now you're threatening to go A4
now I really have to take I have to take
on B4 yeah right take on B4 and how is
this position after Bishop takes B4 does
white have anything in the position I
understand you have control uh and
pressure on the pawn on D5 that
basically keeps this Rook to the div
type to the defense of the Pawn on D5 so
I can go something like root to C okay
one with the idea okay five looks
tempting as well
so let's get out yes size step that
tactic out of that file there's no more
root takes A5
yes
very close to equality I have to say
yeah looking at the position opposite
color Bishops I only have one weakness
as a black I will secure that with the
move King F7 King E6 and then I'm going
to start exchanging pieces on the queen
side feels drawish I think this one is
developing in that direction probably is
going to be a draw
um Ray Robson that this one is almost
done three versus three yeah yeah I
think we're expecting something like
this
and then what's happening in the Neiman
game Sam Sabian versus The Exchange
sacrifice yes accepted but he didn't
take on each five
he played the move Bishop to G4 closing
G file if you close the G file with the
idea that Rook G7 in that you want H6 I
desperately wanted to go H6 yes that
that is a very very uh concrete move but
how do you defend after Rook to d8
then that might be the problem in the
position yeah because if you move the
bishop okay
Knight B3 I want to keep the option of
Bishop takes F6
yes exactly you have to come back with
the move Knight to B3 and now I go Rook
to G8
I have this idea
no way no look at this what is this is
not possible to find us for human beings
by the way none of this will happen
because it just took it before he took
on e4 yes unbelievable and now actually
we're going straight into a very forced
line okay so you probably will take back
and we take it before take on G4 you
take on C3 seems like G7 now I will take
on G7 King D6 I take on C3 with a pawn
with a pawn yes Bishop in the center of
the position and now I have this idea
Rook to E8 you move the king summer then
Rook to C7
and finally I defended the pawn on it if
I lose this one I mean it's six rookies
six H six let's go H6 probably Rook to
E6 yes maybe even Rook takes is that a
move what no I don't you can't okay why
not HG and you're telling me now I get
to F7
and then how many pounds do I have for
the exchange two for the moment two but
I can get a third give me the third you
can you can you can yes you can but I'm
probably going to get something
what happened with the mess we don't
have many people
I think this one is going towards the
draw as well if both players play uh the
best moves and they're quite forced so
I'm not expecting them to shy away uh
too far from uh this variation that we
just looked at so this one most likely
will finish and draw as well still more
than half an hour difference right yes
uh Hans Neiman Hans uh prep really seem
to be shining through in this game a
game that's I find very confounding is
the game between tatv and Rochelle
because even after this queen D3 as
opposed to the usual Queen d2 move the
players have played
right through to one of the most
um I want to say in this Richter Rouser
Sicilian one of the most debated
positions but they've done so at an
incredibly slow pace it's like it's like
that they're almost
Reinventing uh the variations even
though at this moment after E5 and queen
F2 this has all been played before yes
but they're playing it as if everything
is new like and it's like really
confounding way you spend more time I
just wonder maybe is it new for both or
for only one player yeah you have to ask
yourself who isn't Reinventing the wheel
here here because again a lot of uh
games uh from this exact position have
been played before
yes you kind of you you'd expect that
they'd have uh be much much faster
yeah exactly remembering this variation
or trying to maybe switch it to
something else right and again you know
what the Marquee match up in the ladies
is once again the Jennifer uh you versus
Arena Crush game guess what after the
move Rook I've served and Jennifer said
Queen
connecting the Rooks this is always a
good rook f8 and well and rookie one now
so this is where I'm getting a little
crazy you know like why did you play
Rook B1 why did you play Knight on F3 to
E1 to C2 if you wanted to challenge okay
what does it show yes sir what do you
think I mean she's kind of like losing
the track a little bit of what she's
there is it losing the logic a little
bit well it's one of those things that
you you you sit there and you say okay
at this exact moment I'm inspired to do
this and then you go well that's not
really working out so I change my plan
and then at the end of the day it kind
of looks like uh a camel instead of a
horse you know you started with this
idea that you were going to create a
horse and then suddenly you've got all
of the yeah you've got all of these uh
little bumps and lumps and different
mishmash now having said all of that
nothing
right it's still you know a good good
good good fight can you lose like this
yes sir before you get punished yes you
will be
looking forward to punish you at any
moment you right exactly but Arena also
has her difficulties at this moment uh
the night on D7
moved specifically to open up the bishop
but the Knight on D7 isn't great you
would be happy to play Knight takes C2
if this Knight would take its place so
you start to think that I should play
Knight to D7 to C6 or once again you
start to think should I be playing for
G5
sacrificing upon in order to put my
knight on E5 should I be playing for E5
with the idea of capturing and once
again putting my knight on E5 the
problem with a move like Knight E5 is
you are inviting white to jump into the
middle of the board and if you take well
now suddenly this Rook starts to say
okay you know and blessed well I haven't
placed well exactly just in front of you
so uh
and by the way we do have a repetition
between Ray Robson and Christopher and
if this game is a draw once again it
does oh this game will be attractive yes
and you've got to guarantee uh part of
first place so what else do you have for
us uh Christian well I'm looking in the
ladies section and I'm trying to figure
this position out between beg him and
Talia she just played this move Bishop
to D2 at this point I think is where we
left it
a3b3 and now Knight to uh B4 this is the
current position and I'm starting to
like white specifically because I see
this move Knight to E5 to my eyes this
is the most natural move of course
Bishop to D3 is a threat in the position
and take the Rook on F1 take the
exchange even that I have some
compensation as white another threat in
the position is to play C5 we were
discussing about this dream that every a
Greenfield player has in the position
open up Dark Sword Bishop with the move
C5
I can challenge both of those ideas with
the move Queen to B5 immediately take
advantage of this exposure of the Knight
on B4 how do you continue after this do
you want to enter the Lions then with
Knight to C2 probably not you're not
getting out anytime soon after route to
C1 it doesn't make a lot of sense Bishop
to D3 doesn't doesn't make a lot of
sense before so you probably have to go
Knight D5 but this position I'm looking
at it right now I see Rook to C1 coming
I see Knight to E5 coming it feels like
white has achieved everything she wanted
in the position especially after this
move Knight to E5 at some point you're
going to have to kick this with the move
F6 and then that's going to weaken the
position as well or you're going to
exchange this Knight for the bishop
that's going to weaken your King's
position as well so I'm looking at the
position and if begging finds this move
Queen to B5 I think she will have a
pretty significant advantage in this
game so and you were mentioning about
losing time in critical moments Talia
this is exactly what she did only one
missed move this move age six this time
feels like it allowed white to get back
into the position and finish her
development where this move Bishop to D2
Bishop to D2 A3 B3 and Knight to B4
still a lot of things to play for and a
lot of nuances in the position and queen
to B5 is not an easy move to see you can
easily play something like Rook to C1
and be in trouble because you have to do
with ideas of Knight to C2 very
interesting uh game developing in this
one but still is Jennifer you versus
Irena Crush that is hitting up and by
the way this one is over officially Ray
Robson has tied Fabiano caruana at the
top but Fabi is still playing absolutely
uh uh that uh half a point uh
lead uh so so crucial I'm sitting here
looking at the game between Sabina and
Alice Lee and I really don't like at all
what Sabina has done uh after we we got
into this uh London system I was talking
about you know dropping the bishop back
to age seven uh in most positions H3 if
pardon me G3 uh provoked Alice to
putting Sabina in a pin so H3 Bishop
back Bishop back and after this move E5
Sabina really wanted to break the pin
she played G4 and I'm okay with that
move but right here is where in my mind
Sabina made a really
strategic error she played the move E4
and I really don't like this move
whatsoever that weakens the square F4
and in true the E5 E4 wasn't a threat if
I was in sabina's shoes I would have
played Knights at f Juan brought the
Knight to G3 and I would have been happy
to meet the move E4 with the move Knight
H5 give me the bishop and if the bishop
drops back I would love to occupy the F5
squared look what happened instead Alice
got got a great opportunity after the
move E4 Alice played very very well D4
that shuts down this bishop exactly
exactly that shut down the other Bishop
as well because now you have a Pawn on
e4 but much more importantly after the
move Knight
F1 guess where Alice is going night to
eat exactly
uh we're caught up with the players but
I really like Black's uh control of the
center she's got space in the center but
more importantly she has like a
permanent uh Square which she can play
and F5 might look like a really good
square but it's not permanent there's
always G7 G6 so I like Alice's position
very much as she's up against the former
U.S champion
and social media right now yes oh great
oh are you ready for questions oh yes
Anastasia yes so let's let's go first of
all who is it from it's from Lars
Togo
so he's asking who is the most promising
of the young contenders uh let's say
under 20 yes we're about to succeed
Magnus at the world's strongest player
well we always talk about these Juniors
and uh we have a lot of very very very
strong Juniors we saw from the Olympiad
and what uh the the team India too as
well as those
fantastic yes but then we're always
reluctant to say future world champion
because the junior players have this
habit of going to the university and
finding other careers outside of chess
jump in on the question uh and I think
we should definitely highlight the
American players as well coming up we
have abhimanyu Mishra who just broke the
record of the youngest Grandmaster ever
history he's only 13 years of age and
he's almost close to 2600. so that guy
has a bright future and very dedicated
as well as Christopher you as you can
see in this event he's coming up with
brilliant preparation he can beat the
best chess players on the planet he
proved that against Wesley so in this
tournament at least so Christopher you
we have Hans Neiman as well he's still
under 20. he's only 17 years of age so
there's definitely an emerging crop of
talent in American chess and we have our
eyes on all of that to be honest but
also let's not forget of course the
Indian team the one you mentioned yes
sir with Gucci you know always pregnant
and other players I think they made a
big news now in India by after beating
Magnus Carlson in his event
organized these days as well and I mean
all of them actually already managed to
feel how is it to beat Magnuson
progression yes it will not be a mistake
also to say that one of them will
definitely fight really soon for the
world championship title I'm sure we'll
see some of them in the game next
candidates tournament I mean and and
actually I think maybe they have even
more chances because like what you
mentioned yes sir that some of the
Juniors especially the American Juniors
have really great opportunities ahead
they can study in some universities
Indian players of course they also have
these opportunities but I think there
are kind of more focused uh and they
have such a great example of vision and
who won the became the World
Championship uh who won the title five
times and to prove that you can be a
professional chess player and you can be
still the hero of the nation you know
he's the hero but I want to ask you
another question related to this I mean
we here in the United States are
seriously missing Carissa Yip uh she's
not playing in the Championships because
she's going at Stanford she's a freshman
at Stanford she really has to work hard
in the ladies game who are the up and
coming
uh female players that you go wow that's
the pragananda of the ladies game this
really good actually Point you'll think
about it we've got another question
as well as you know baby Sarah you know
Kazakhstan players from Kazakhstan are
doing really great but we have a second
question this one is from the Texas Big
Data get out of here get out of here
and how much does Christian bench press
Squat and dead lift and is the amount
more than one thousand cumulative yes
pounds pounds how does that help no I
think the the question I really was
thinking in terms of a thousand kilos
kilos I'm not 100 pounds no no no no I
actually don't live too much I only do
body weight exercises I don't leave too
much I do Jiu Jitsu and that's about it
only I I and how does that help me
staying active staying in shape help my
feeder rating I mean it helps me as a
professional commentator it gives me
more energy it helps me as a
professional coach he sets a good
example for my students and as a player
as well because it gives me a lot of
energy and we see this in 13 round
events like we have here at the USS
championships these players are relying
on their last drop of energy going into
the championship rounds and it's so so
important that you stay fit you stay
active you maintain a good cardio
routine as well as good lifting routine
so I think it's critical and all of them
are doing it let's look at Sarah savian
he's always in the gym you look at Hans
Neiman he's always in the gym at the
pool we've seen him plenty of times when
you look at carwana he's always in the
gym as well all of them are doing
something to maintain their energy
levels they believe that Christian has
to also keep some energy for an out
after party you know some dancing you
know I was thinking uh as a lowly
podcaster
possible
leave those podcasters
so weights aren't part of your training
not so much okay I think also Maurice
Ashley he's also you can see him in this
game all the time yes he's much more I
tried to go to gym a couple of times but
he is always there you know if he's in
the town you can find him pretty
impressive uh you have the game of fobby
behind you as yeah not a lot of things
have happened actually they're following
uh the lines that we were discussing uh
he played Bishop to B4 right take on B4
Rook to B3 this is the position right
now uh Fabiano is thinking so this one I
mean we'll let it go for the moment
right we'll see what's uh going to
happen in the future this is the game
that uh intrigues me the most to be
honest because Hans did find the best
moves it seems like Sam decided to take
with a bishop on C3 not with a B Pawn
and now we have this position Rook to F7
how do we assess it I mean we know that
black is better black black cannot be
worse in the position right The Rook on
F7 nicely protects uh H7 you're not
getting to my weakness anytime soon and
in the meantime maybe I will have a way
to arrange my pieces and put some
problems on your overextended Pawns
I understand this move A4 he's trying to
put a Pawn on A5 and that's going to
mean that the [ __ ] Pawn C3 most likely
is going to be Untouchable because if
you leave the pawn on A3 I have ideas of
A5 B5 and then B4 at the right moment
it's not easy to make it happen of
course because of course A5 I take on A5
and you lose a pawn it's not easy to
happen but you can see that in the
future the potential of that Rook to A8
A5 B5 Rook B7 King C5 and then B4 and
finally I made it happen if I manage to
kick your Bishop from C3 where it has a
very nice Outpost given by this Pawn on
B2 then probably I will develop a nice
initiative as black so that's why we see
this move A4 played by Sam Sevin still
sam7 and only 22 minutes on his clock
right now definitely in the worst
position maybe Hans has an opportunity
to score a hat trick is is that correct
I think he won his last two games
against Slenderman and moradia badia now
has the opportunity
you're absolutely right yeah okay and
still hanser actually said that his
participation here and the result so far
is not so great right he was really uh
not so optimistic well he keeps saying
that but he's on 50 it's not bad I don't
know why he is exactly this is his first
U.S Championship so a debut where you
score 50 and potentially even better
I'll take it by the way yes sir when you
had your first championships what do you
think about it I was 19 and uh gee
would you consider it what would you
consider it good 50 or you would also
put some pressure on you I would have
put it you see so it's a sign of the
person who really tries to achieve
something now I have to think when did I
win the U.S Championship maybe I was
you don't understand
I don't think it was my rookie year I
don't think it was my debut yes I
remember drawing a few games but I was
close I was like 20 maybe when I won my
first year so you have to put goals
in front of you like maybe something
which is not achievable at the moment
but somehow you have to push exactly
exactly big achievements yes indeed
that's exactly right icons will manage
to win today maybe and uh even improve
his score even more uh I'm looking at
the game of Irina and Jennifer and this
one kind of defies uh the um I want to
say accepted practice because uh after
after the the move to Rook E1 came E55
closing this e-file yes exactly
um and you know we're always told to
take the two Bishops and Jennifer jumped
at that opportunity but in this this
position you kind of look at this bishop
on D3 and you kind of go well that's
maybe not a great Bishop like for
example let's just imagine I took on C2
Anastasia
recapture with the bishop yes and then I
really really want you to capture
the pawn on E5 because otherwise you'll
take good book by yourself right I will
uh win the pot on F4 this is the
situation I want I want to play this
very very nice night I call it
in the middle of the board versus you if
I can get you to play b2b3 the bishop is
really
kind of septic it doesn't
it just said Bishop he's not really
happy and I really like uh his choice uh
is pardon me I really like Arena's
position not her choice uh I'm not
saying that Knight takes C2 is maybe
there's some reasons why I don't really
have to trade the bishop and I could
start with a move like Bishop H6 but my
first initial reaction when I saw this
position is give me black arena is in
really really a good position at the
moment is time a factor yes Jennifer was
taking a lot of times I would say 25
minutes for uh Jennifer with 21 moves to
go yes
42 minutes 42 minutes for arena but I
have to say Arena's position is much
more fluid much easier to play much
easier to play yeah so I like this uh
position for
um Arena do they have other options like
just take on a four for example in this
position just to understand like I don't
know maybe we can we have this exact
moment yeah but we cannot okay yes
because the saruk is on the same file
yes exactly so immediately before and
even if we have even we have check not
recaptures on D4 and your queen is under
attack yes exactly yes so just to
demonstrate to finish the thought yeah
yeah but uh this move Bishop H6 but
looks good for uh Arena we have guest in
studio uh Christian thank you Yasser we
are with a Ray Robson Ray first of all
how is uh how is this game because
Christopher was just like blitzing out
every single move giving you an exchange
for the attack how did you feel at that
point
yeah it well it wasn't that pleasant but
it also wasn't that unpleasant it would
have been unpleasant if I didn't know
about this line at all but I I I did
fortunately so yeah Bishop D3 I knew I'm
supposed to
take the exchange and it's fine actually
I thought maybe Black's even supposed to
be a little bit better in this line but
uh of course I didn't remember
everything so I knew take and it feels
like it's always about when you started
this line the last time when did you
study this line the last time oh
originally I yeah I probably studied a
while ago but fortunately sometime
during the tournament I like looked at
it for like you know two seconds so I
had a slightly better memory than I
would have but still I didn't actually
concretely remember anything
um except okay new D6 G6 this position
should definitely be fine and I was
almost certain that Queen E7 should be
the best move but it's one of the moves
Bishop to E6 seems to be pretty decent
as well yeah that's the main other one I
was thinking about
um but then you guys this is my first to
go into this line
and now you have to go F5 and this type
of position
ah yeah I I think I completely
hallucinate I thought like Queen D7
would I would get mated somehow but like
my night's still covering Jason yeah so
maybe this one was also possible but I
think Queen E7 is probably what I
analyzed originally whenever I first
analyzed this so and if you do want to
equalize the position this seems to be a
very good uh path forward so I have to
take take the main I thought Knight D5
was the main thing I looked at and now I
think I should play Queen E5 the thing
is if I check on E1 Bishop F1 he always
has besides the mating thread says Queen
f8 check and Bishop H6 threats as well
so I thought for example if you let's
say you go something like this
page six and then that's a an extra
piece
very nice so I thought Knight D5 Queen
E5 and
um for some reason I thought C4 was what
I had analyzed and I was trying to
figure out why can't he take on C7
instead of C4
um and I figured probably it's Knight F5
uh he can't take his now back rank mate
so Queen F4
and now I can do check Bishop F1 and
something like Rook d8 so now he doesn't
have this moving his Bishop with Tempo
and now I counter attack him and
probably I win or something yeah went to
C4 or something like Bishop C6 yeah I
assumed I was winning here yeah yeah
you're gonna get the Checkmate so yeah
Queen E5 C4 and I didn't remember you
know what's happening uh I mean what
exactly I should play but I knew I
should be okay instead he went Bishop G5
and he played it super fast yeah well he
knew both moves and I guess he just
decided to play this one I think he was
also trying to figure out if I still
knew this position
um and yeah I was thinking obviously
about Queen E5 as well and I think he
was gonna play Queen Bishop F4 yes
yeah he was saying it should be around
equal
um but I saw like F6 is very safe like
probably the line we go for it's kind of
forced and I didn't think I would really
have any losing chances there so yeah in
the end I decided just to go for that
but obviously I didn't get many winning
chances I don't think either coming into
this uh game obviously have a point
behind Fabiano playing against Chris for
you who is struggling in the last few
rounds what are you trying to get
something out of the opening were you
trying to equalize what was your
strategy
yeah I was thinking at first I was like
oh yeah I should like really just go for
it I mean I would really be great to at
least be tied going to the last round
but uh that's not really the way I
usually play with black these days and
then in the end I decided okay I'm just
gonna play normally just play my normal
openings and he usually goes for a fight
so even against you know stronger high
rated players so I was hoping yeah we
might get a game and then we just see
what would happen but
um
yeah obviously I I never expected this
line I mean he doesn't usually go for
the Berlin and then I was thinking okay
maybe just gotta like make a quiet draw
and then of course he went for the
bishop D3 so it was kind he kind of
reverted back to his usual style anyway
but yeah it seemed like he was just well
prepared Jeffrey tomorrow with the white
pieces in the final round is the must
win for you
I assume I don't know how fabi's doing
is he like uh winning or something no
probably no okay probably more like a
draw yeah because I was trying to figure
out when this bishop before moved
yeah I moved 22 that was I left what so
ah I saw an A5 there's Bishop A5 I guess
right yes because I was thinking what if
he tries A5 A4 and then the idea that
Bishop C5 yeah but I guess you could
just take an A5 yes can take on A5 they
seems to be pretty decent well yeah so
if I'm half Point behind Fabiano I may
think he's white against Lavon yeah
um so it is a must when I would say if I
want to have a chance to tie
um
yeah that's always difficult situation I
think I was in the same situation once
in U.S Championship
um and going to the last round I was
half Point behind it Carl he was going
to be 15. yeah he's gonna be white
against onishook I was going to be black
against karev and I managed to win that
game but unfortunately he also managed
to win so at least I did I did the best
I could I could in that game I'll try to
do that again tomorrow I think I've had
five draws and three wins and then a
bunch more draws so hopefully I can get
squeeze one more winning for the end of
the tournament but yeah it's been been a
really tough tournament guys yeah
congratulations Ray our old success for
you tomorrow in the final round and uh
well keep up the good work yeah looking
forward because it's I hope we'll still
have this motivation you spoke that you
really want to win one day the U.S
Championship so it's gonna be really
interesting fight tomorrow looking
forward thank you absolutely uh you've
got to have goals and here it is our
current standings uh with one game
already in the history books exactly
array Robson made a draw and now he is
uh he has seven and half points the same
as Fabiano but Fabiano is still uh he
keeps playing with his game yeah in case
of draw Fabiano will have eight points
and he'll be on the first place and Rey
will be of a point behind him let's say
that that he's rooting for saying come
on and we've got another happy birthday
this time for the big boss Randy
singfield
congratulations very very nice Randy
it's his 21st anniversary
nice and by the way Arena crushes we go
to break did play the move Knight takes
C2 and she's enjoying an advantage at
this moment uh against Jennifer as we go
to break
see on the other side
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the St Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
Global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique non-profit
institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame
Cutting Edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art Innovative programming
explores the intersection of Chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back to round 12 of US
championships we have current standings
in women's section first and Jennifer
you keeps leading with eight points
Irina Crush has seven and a half they
play together against each other and
and Irene I think has slightly better
position but absolutely there are Advent
some Adventures I think right now anyway
we'll check it later Salia Cervantes is
on the third place after winning four
games in a row and Alice Lee is on the
first place with six and half points and
then the open uh section we already have
one result in the record books Ray
Robson made a draw exactly with
Christopher you and now he actually
shares the first place with Fabiano
Carona but Fabian is still playing his
game against Sam Shanklin let's say Rey
is rooting for example well in this game
but Lanier and Jeffrey Lanier and Sam
sevillan also still playing let's just
jump right into the game of Arena crash
for a moment because we had a moment of
rewind Panic yes okay we left it at this
moment when Knight takes E2 Bishop takes
C2 had been played and I was really kind
of expecting but H6 is kind of a nice
move let's trade off the dark Square
Bishops let's get a good night on E5 we
already know no Arena went for something
completely different takes takes takes
takes check and he went here yes and
then you said and I'm looking forward
Professor look at this Rook of four and
I went oh my gosh that's completely
winning yeah Queen takes F4 Queen takes
E1 with maid on next turn that one's
easy I take your Rook Rook oh my gosh
okay look at this Arena just wins yes
and we were shocked wait a minute wait a
minute uh Jennifer can't couldn't have
blundered so so routinely is that and
then it's sort of like oh Jesus kind of
saves the day maybe black is still
better but whoa whoa whoa uh that that
that that it doesn't lose so let's say
you have to remove King H1 but if you
don't see this move just three I mean
you
immediately you know like okay for
finish how could I have messed such a
strong move now a couple of options here
for
um Arena one is you know like okay let's
attack that Bishop let's reinforce the
threat of Queen F1 we've probably forced
to play G3 anyway and then you know you
start yeah you start looking at those
kinds of things yeah let's check or you
kind of go well I like after G3 I'd like
to put my knight uh bring my knight into
the game first and you know should I now
you know check this move G5
wait what what you know and actually as
Bishop F5 is not possible in that
position because oh sorry which one yes
I mean 95 is just 395 Bishop B5 Bishop
E5 yes yes three but it's Queen G2 so
it's not so dangerous well still a nice
position for black right I mean I can
I can even do Rook F2 here uh yeah
going and this is just a great position
for arena
uh how big is it how big is Arena's
Advantage I really like her position I
just don't know how big the advantage is
Christian objectively is pretty decent
but I think she lost a little bit of her
Advantage previously so really yes yes
maybe Rook to uh at this point after
taking taking with a rook now why don't
we just simply take this guy
what's the problem with picking up a
pond what about some Bishop just six
ideas I have a feeling you're going to
lose something yes something your Rook
takes a four now I go Queen to G7 I'm
defending and attacking at the same time
history is on tap yeah if you go
something like let's say Bishop to D3
right yeah then Bishop to C3 is coming
yeah that's a problem that's key yeah so
just taking the pawn seems to have uh
given Irena a completely decisive
Advantage wow she did nothing just take
the poem yes just take the pawn but it's
easier said than done of course the
training
she might have missed Rook takes a 4G
probably maybe this is what she knows
it's so easy to miss seven years if you
are winning and perhaps you look at this
position and exactly stopping
calculating King H1 because you see Rook
takes a four and you only look at Bishop
to E3 and you see that after Rook to E8
you're winning again right yes yeah and
you can take on B to where whenever you
want you can start calculating later on
if King F2 you don't have anything bad
other than just take the pawn
unbelievable but maybe she missed this
move King to H1 and after who takes F4
G3 and by the way I've never seen such
yes it's still equal but yeah I'm not
sure who has the better side of equality
in the position okay still better Knight
to E5 but you see the trend is
definitely in Jennifer's uh Arena's
favor in her favor yeah absolutely you
can play the move B3 you can take on E5
I don't think you want to take on E5
because I mean this is just going to be
such a difficult Pleasant defense right
Queen to H4 is coming I have so much
control over the dark squares and you
don't have any counter chances the
position I don't think you want to see
this on the board but what I do think
you want to see is probably just play
normal chest defend the pawn with B3
maybe even Bishop to D3 and just wait
it's not going to be pretty you're not
going to have a good position for a very
long time but the material is quite
limited and maybe you will be able to
save this one with perfect plan and this
is what Jennifer needs to do if she
wants to maintain her lead going into
the final round absolutely and for begum
fans unfortunately for begum she did not
find that move Queen B5 against Talia
she did not she did not she actually
played this is the moment where Queen B5
would have turned the tables as kind of
a surprise move first of all you get out
of the bishop D3 and second of all you
make it that much more difficult for
your opponent to play C5 because the
Knight on uh D4 and B6 would be hanging
in those cases she actually played the
move Rook D1 and this is what Talia
needed to play this very nice sequence
of moves starting with uh C7 a c is
starting with Bishop C2 and C5 blasting
open this diagonal everything is working
everything is working for Talia and
after this move 95 93 she even had this
nice tactic Bishop takes D3
black is better I don't think there's
any question about that Talia said maybe
I'm just winning
with this move uh C5 takes D4 the idea
is two nights are hanging if you try to
move one night well you do get the
bishop but
yes and it's all Italian it feels like
Bishop D3 was much more proficient
though was it yes because once you take
on D4 I think this opens up the
possibility for white to try to get back
into the game uh through some
compensation and that is with the move
Knight to A4 but she needs to find this
move White Knight to A4 yes I wasn't
even looking in that direction exactly
and now you take on A4 most likely right
and now I go Knight E5
Knight E5 I still attack the Knight on
A4 and I still threatened to take on D4
if you do take on E3 and I take on E3
back with the pawn it already feels like
I have enough compensation right Rook C1
is coming the Knight on E5 is nicely
blocking the bishop you are a pawn up
but it doesn't look that good that's not
what I had intended wow
is important if she doesn't find Knight
A4 though Talia is definitely winning
probably she will because I mean you
don't have the alternatives
to find something else yes right but
maybe it's not that easy because maybe
you're not even thinking about going
towards that side of course yeah you're
you're kind of blocked you your mind's
not looking at Knight A4 that's not the
move that comes readily to mind and of
course even after Knight A4 black is
still better right but it feels like
white slowly but surely at least gets
some play in the position
yes I mean
yeah wow okay uh we'll keep those two in
mind I just want to see how Alice guys
yes sorry if Talia wins her fifth that's
what I'm saying she does she bounces
right up and could potentially and if I
read it with her game then she ties with
Jennifer that's in the second position
no no if Arena wins she you actually
first yeah she replaces
and guess what they're playing tomorrow
Jennifer and Talia they play tomorrow
yes yes and the arena will play against
Thunder don't skip which is awesome
so once again like if Arena wins her
game she will be on the first position
immediately and Jennifer goes to the
second place then and then perhaps they
will share it with you now you know the
crazy part about these two competitors
and you look at that light score 11 wins
nine losses nine draws Arena's sitting
there saying to herself of all the
players in the field going into the last
round game
why do I have exactly
I mean please could it be Alice Lee or
even anybody else but Anna has had uh
well her her share victories and for
Jennifer tomorrow this is a a well if
Talia wins Talia is soaring I mean
wow wow wow yeah it's gonna be a really
big fight I mean what else we could ask
for right for the last round of the U.S
Chess Championship in fact that's all I
ever asked that's a dramatic Finance
and uh just a second I I'm not used to
hearing this Lavon who hasn't been
having just a dress tournament let let's
just you know put that out there it does
happen he is actually
winning the game let's let's jump into
that one I haven't seen where are you
Lavon I haven't played attention to your
game he's up against elshon who my
goodness uh when you talk about it bad
tournaments and let's get out of here
for elshon he's just uh it's been all
bad
well Lavon is enjoying an extra Pawn at
this moment and we can see A5
H5 is hanging there's also what you've
just said there are some ideas before
Bishop we wanted to know exactly exactly
and yeah well
if nothing else that's that's Pawn
number two and maybe no Bishop C4
probably this is the worst of everything
I'm just Rook takes lure good morning
um
[Music]
seven it's crazy yeah
the only you otherwise might be six
right yes the bishop would have to go to
this horrifying square a seven
um no this looks wonderful of course for
Lavon and uh many many promising and I
think what you just said maybe just the
simplest yeah I mean I'm trying but
one yeah I guess you Bishop A3 is maybe
the only possibility and then what
you've learned it should be two Rook
takes or Rook C2 then you should be
three yes right look at this Bishops I
know they look a little bit weird but uh
you haven't lost material
so maybe bishop A3 but uh looks very
very good but but more importantly how
is Fabby doing in his game with Sam
Shanklin when we left it it looked even
if Steven is that still the case uh it
is yeah it is yes yes we still have
pretty much the same configuration
nothing has happened no new weaknesses
in the position the a pawn is not going
anywhere anytime soon this one seems to
be going towards the draw but guess what
Hans has built up pretty much a decisive
Advantage wow right now take a look at
what's happening in this game Sam Savion
versus Hans Neiman separation has been
created on the queen side and finally I
have a potential pass Pawn on B5 Rook to
D2 we're expecting somehow to be able to
uh defend this Pawn on F2 and then at
the right moment I'm going to take on B2
and I'm going to transition into a
rook's end game and that might be
problematic because this B Pawn is
running down the board and is running
fast right this seems to be just simply
decisive is the only way maybe to defend
yes yes so let's see let's see Rook to
F3 take take take take
wow
now maybe we can go towards this I
cannot go to before because I have to be
careful about that could I just ask you
about Rook F3 check King A2 uh Rook
takes no Rook F3 yes yes
I like what you were saying about take
the pawn on B2 so let's see are we in
time though take take who's first king
two
yes I don't want to go to a E4 because
yes to be a check so probably I have to
go to G4 right okay B4 F4
and this is just a queen upon ending oh
my gosh it's not moving again
get into this position this is not what
this is a draw yes it is
so Sam pardon me Hans has to squeeze in
a Tempo and
well for good reason Sam is not getting
far away from his board he only has two
minutes on his clock right now and still
there's a couple of moves to go so
actually just one more move for Assam
two more moves for Hans in the position
to reach 40 moves but Hans has 55
minutes 55 minutes by the way there's no
problem for Hans in in this situation
wow
so I mean again we're saying great crap
by Hans Neiman and also Christopher you
today I mean both of those players had
big advantages on the on on time and
sorry about this game with Fabi excuse
me but why isn't Fabi just better you're
saying it's even but I'm just thinking
the a pawn isn't that like the dangerous
Critter but there's there's no way you
can push it so if I go King E6 and Rook
A7 and try to go A4 yeah Rook A4 so then
your Rook is kind of okay let's make a
move for King E6 sure let's go E3 E3
let's go Rook A7 even though Arthur King
E6 maybe I can even start thinking about
giving you a check with rookie 3.
and maybe that's why he's leaving the E3
Square
give you a check and rookie eight maybe
with some ideas from d8 oh no sorry okay
so just a second so H4 I went King E6
you went not E3 but Rook E3 check I move
my king are you sure you want to allow
me Bishops I mean yeah you could go five
and then what's up
okay but wait but rookie five doesn't
threaten anything no not yet I'm trying
just to kind of uh so you you will just
keep moving your poems
okay this one wins uh wins the pawn
right yeah but I but when you I mean
remember
rookie four rookie four Rook A4 okay
um oh where's my Rook uh I could go Rook
B4 uh ah tricky I cannot take on A5
because of Discovery Channel check so
now you're I I'm I'm trying to put
advances just in case if you play King
seven I taken before okay I'm getting my
Pawn going yeah
Rook to D5 you played Bishop
how dangerous it is is it so
people yes and one move away from Bishop
takes and coronation is coming yeah
maybe not okay because I cannot play E3
really right I mean
I'm still ready to go here and I don't
have any defense no I don't I'm not on
time but it's it certainly but I I was
thinking it feels like this is a bit too
much okay
I mean what if I win if I what if I
trade D5 Pawn for like right the
question that I was asking is okay you
get your rook in these awkward setups
but
um I don't think there's any progress
there's no progress to be made here I
don't see I'm kind of like mystified
that
that this Rook is tied up so let's say I
go back and I don't know you go yeah
and
somehow I thought I would hmm
maybe even if you sacrifice an exchange
how big an advantage is that I don't
know I thought it was probably a choice
he's the one with the passer
it was a like kind of confusing to me uh
all right Sam sevillan uh we kind of
lost track of Lanier because Jeffrey
Zhang and Lanier was another important
to fight for the standings exactly and
this was that Queen's Gambit accepted a
long time ago and I was explaining I
never played this as black and Lanier
said you know what I've been working
with my chess engines
and it says it's okay they say I'm okay
I believe them
wow
okay and after all this exchanges so
what do we have I can see that it's
pretty cool right right four versus four
Anastasia nothing no problem here I
expect to draw in that game I wonder a
wonder versus Darvish
what's going on hold on one two three
four five
six six and this one two three four five
six but I'm thinking I like Black's
position even though there's two sets of
double pawns and a split Pawn I'm seeing
active play for black
oh wait wait Knight D5 check oh I had
wanted you to Simply step back but 95
checks where do you go you lose your
pound on F6 and then that goes back
maybe but then you would lose the upon
on it
[Music]
yeah I think that this is okay this
looks okay uh D5 and or 94.
um Christian turning it to you uh what
has caught your eye well actually it
does seem like Levon might just be
taking this one very soon uh right now
there is a pawn up there's probably the
second one dropping this uh right moment
Knight takes H5 you cannot go I mean you
can go Bishop to E2 but you're not
actually winning uh my piece I go to A1
and unfortunately you're just simply
going to be lost you can do this but not
afterward to be one you cannot take on
E5 because of Rook to E1 so all this
geometry is working in White's favor you
can take on H5 but after taking on E5
you have so many weaknesses you're
losing another pawn and then my H Pawn
is going down the board also my a pawn
is still there to keep some pieces some
resources uh on that side for black so
this one is just pretty much over at
this point if he takes on H5 and that's
not the only way you can start with Rook
to A1 you will lose some points on this
side uh what's happening in the Wesley
game guys is Wesley building up some
sort of an advantage against Alexander
Linderman who once again has been
struggling yes not only in this event
but going into this event as well in the
last two months he actually lost 60
rating points wow he went from 2600 to
25 35 right now so it's not looking good
and of course
there's a name on H1 so there there's a
big threat right now I am threatening to
take 25. you have to defend against it
how do you defend against it maybe F3
like this I don't think you have time to
take take
step three because I have Roku G5 who is
mating wow exactly exactly if you go
here Queen to C5 King here I give you
another check I put you on a dark swear
and then I'm getting my Bishop involved
and that's going to mean that you're in
trouble so are quite an intriguing
position in this one ig6 we're expecting
F3 and then the question is how much of
an advantage Wesley has managed to get
in this position still the material is
quite limited so if we exchange a few
more pieces and then we get into a major
piece and game Queen and Rook versus
queen and Rook the King on G7 is also a
bit weak right so you have to keep an
eye out for that as black this one is
quite intriguing Wesley definitely
putting the pressure can we take only
five and then look at one check maybe
there are some ideas Rook H1 yes can I
give some Perpetual or not oh but I'm
not trying to make a drawing
I'm sure there might be a Perpetual yeah
but maybe G4 is something better Maybe
not maybe not what yes I think maybe
there is no actually yes King will run
away maybe yes yes yes and I I don't
think Wesley's thinking about making a
draw yes I think he wants to win this
one
maybe G4 here yes yes so some ideas
wow and it's a pin again like Bishop
before Queen if I yes exactly so it's
like it's a double-edged like if you're
very doublesh inaccurate move you can
lose immediately very double edged and
actually they're pretty close on time as
well 20 minutes for Wesleyan 15 minutes
for Alexander leneron still 11 moves to
go into the time control so it's a very
complicated position still another
question for you in that Wesley so gay
yeah F3 Knight takes E5 root takes E5
King G8 no but I can think I can still
oh you still think yeah yeah again yeah
I have a whole battery yeah that is true
that is true
Alice Lee uh it looks to me like Alice
Lee is crashing through uh sabina's
Queen side the last few moves we've seen
some action taking place on the king
side there was a trade on H3 uh
C5 C4 by Alice and look at this takes
takes Queen C3 hitting uh the tender
Quantum D B3 as well as the Rook on B1
uh
help me out here for example if you want
just I wanted to uh
go Knight C5 Pond hunting
all right how to defend it exactly
no how you can no and also with the
light squared Bishop missing yes uh it
means that the king side you know there
can always be you know this light Square
Bishop on G6 can if this bishop somehow
let's drag it to the G4 Square you can
see how uh sabina's King side will be
really swiss cheese Jennifer you versus
Arena Crush we let's catch up with them
when we left it we left this and it was
that Rook takes F4 shock yes yes when
you pointed out Rook F4 I was like oh my
gosh Jennifer loses the U.S Women's
Championship in a single move Queen F6
G2 G3 Knight E5 uh Big Ideas that's a
fork as well as give me the pawn so she
dealt with both of those threats Knight
F3 Knight C4 but maybe offering her Pawn
Arena said I'll take that one H4
King G2 and Arenas a pawn to the good
but here's where it kind of gets a
little bit weird if these two Bishops
were removed it's it's completely
completely lost I mean it's gone but
with the with that Bishop how can I say
it uh defending F4 for just a moment
maybe maybe maybe well I mean I like the
extra Pawn but it's not it's not that
clear yes
it sure actually it's a good move to
prevent G5 right like just she keeps
control over her father with this move
and maybe sometimes who knows hoping to
create something on the king side
exactly and open the position a little
bit anyway if the Fight Continues here
in this big time I was thinking that he
fell asleep for some I mean if she wins
this game against Sabina then she'll
have seven and a half points right also
you know trying but she's on the outside
looking in as far as the podium is
concerned it's all about Talia too if
Talia
uh were to win her game and Jennifer
were to lose
then she's a half a point behind Arena
going into the last round saying if I
can beat Jennifer and go on a 6-0 streak
or something of that nature I'll be
doing really good but how good is it
well guess what I mean I can't blame uh
begum I mean
that would she played Knight E2 captures
Rook C1 captures captures Queen E6 and
after all of the excitement it looks
like tally is just Upon Us yeah you
could you can take this Knight but I'm
gonna take this oh wait a minute B7
what's going on here yeah yeah yeah hold
on just a second yes and by the way
Lavon his first win in the tournament
and it comes against elshon who's just
been giving points to everybody uh Lavon
said I will take it yes yeah
take them 12 rounds to win the game wait
a minute I I'm hanging everything I'm
hanging the the The Rook on A1 I'm
hanging The Rook on d8 well that's the
problem you're not only upon them right
okay everything is hanging everything is
hanging and actually you cannot defend
the Rook on A1 uh for four minutes
because the bishop is on D3 yes but wait
a minute okay so I take
yes yes
take on d8 I guess you just chart let's
take back okay one so how is this
position
I have Bishop B2 also that needs to be
actually what do you play after which P2
I have no idea yes let's
try it out what let's try it out Bishop
B2 B2 B2 Bishop also
so yeah it is yes do it later so how
many pieces we have broken one maybe I
still can play something cookie one a
little tasty eight and the problem is
that somehow I feel of course I feel it
the position is just bad you know like
you don't have a move that's your one
but Queen four is also a move but no no
Bishop D4 you played Bishop D4 I yes to
check by the way Bishop takes B6 is on
the board right now Bishop takes B with
all of these pieces hanging you just you
just sense uh you there is something you
you have to be very very uh aware okay
so Bishop takes B6 just a second hold on
I'm a mess I messed up so Bishop takes
Rook Bishop takes A1 Bishop takes d8
Bishop B2
um
sorry I I'm just going into a short
stall here
um maybe there is not like okay
93. I'm thinking of F5 no you take my
knight sorry
I don't know I also don't like literally
after Rook did it feels like really bad
for yeah but if you look at the pieces
if I if I have to go rookie one Rook
takes the I I feel like I'm I'm in deep
uh trouble playing like this I don't
think I can get away with it at the
moment I don't see the refutation but it
definitely feels like Talia has uh big
advantages big advantages at this exact
moment again I'm sorry I just want to
see Jennifer you versus arena with King
G2 because I didn't check the times
the clock
say that I see 16 for your Arena and I
don't see for how much
four or ten ten ten minutes
15 years yeah it just kind of dropped
precipitously just at the end there so
H5 kg2 Arena
uh 13 moves for the time control
but this one feels much better than a
few moves ago right
I have Rook H1 followed by H5 maybe I
have my own counter chances sure you
took a pawn but
at it's one cost it's lost right
Dynamic play in the position right do
you remember what Jennifer said in her
in her interview is that you have to
take every game like you were playing
the last turn this the last round yes
like maybe it's a good approach to play
every game like it's your last game in
the championship right so well it's
getting to that point because
of it around here and uh all the games
uh in progress what do you have on your
board Christian actually I have this
game of Anna zatonsky versus Nazi
paikidze and I see Anna in pole position
as well and why is this an important
game not only for the standings but also
we know how crucial of a matchup we have
tomorrow between Anna zatonski and Irina
Crush so if Anna wins this one I think
right now she's on Sixth uh position if
I'm not mistaken she will get some
momentum going clear right and
definitely we'll be looking to fight
against Irina Crush for much more than
just beating her old rival but actually
finishing up at on a very respectable
position so a big moment right now for
Anna zatoski in her tournament against
Nazi by kids now
um my approach to this position is like
it's very very good for Anna I love the
imbalances of Knight versus Bishop
because there are certain moments when
the bishop is outstanding and then there
are other moments when the night was
outstanding in Arena's game versus
Jennifer you when if you take off the
dark script Bishops
I thought Arena's night on E5 would
absolutely dominate Jennifer's light
squared Bishop in this position I see
the reverse is true I see this Knight on
D4 absolutely dominating and the only
thing I want this bishop to remain there
for the rest of the game and that means
I want that yes okay yes sir you kind of
I want to that conclusion once you
realize that this bishop is playing this
very awkward defensive uh nurse made to
this Pawn you want to play this move uh
C5
now the crazy part is everybody would be
inclined to play A4 I think this is
actually playing into White's hands what
do I mean
I need a passer I need a pass Bond I
can't just win the game you know because
I've got this Knight on D4 and you know
you're you're in a defensive mode I need
to pass Pawn now once I play B3 I got my
past Bond now I need my king over there
to escort the pawn up the board but you
start to understand that at play King F2
so that I can play King E3 and in the
very very near future I want to play B3
not B4 if I play the move B4 you don't
have to play on poisson but I want to
play B3 and get a secure pass a bond
it's going to take me a long long while
and yeah yeah yeah
but look at black structure yeah of
course no this H5
isolated isolated what did your what did
your teacher tell you about Paul Islands
you know you got a lot of Pawn Islands
doesn't it yes many many yeah
also the problem for Black's King is
like where's the ideal position for
black skin if you imagine I played the
move F4 yes where does your king go
there's there are no squares yes maybe
to be seven right it's not like you're
gonna King is going to walk to F5 or G4
if I've got my Pawn on F4 so I'm seeing
a very very big Advantage I don't know
what the computer says what about Rook
A5 for example
ah no cannot play two moves yes no it's
okay it's okay
yeah and preventing B3 at least so if
you put it now this three I'll take on
B3 you cannot take with the Rook Rook C5
exactly but I'm in no hurries yes that's
a process so like let's say you you you
move your King again I'm in no hurries
it's like your king can't go to G you
can go to G5 and and even try to go to
H4 but here's what I'm saying is that
eventually there's you you won't be able
to prevent me from playing the move B3
and if I ever get this then I'm going to
play A4 and slowly slowly slowly away we
go so I do see this as an Anna is really
having a bad competition
if you
however what I was saying at the start
of our show if you win your last two
games of a tournament it's sort of like
even a bad tournament yes it starts to
feel like something wasn't so bad and
like you get the hope maybe if I would
wake up earlier then I could even win
this tournament yes
exactly exactly so these last two rounds
that's why we call them the championship
rounds because it really does create
champions
and by the way another result just come
through Lanier did draw that four versus
four two Rooks no real fireworks in a
couple of games uh uh from this round
Christian absolutely but we do have
fireworks in this one between abrahamian
and Rochelle lewand has been having a
pretty bad uh tournament for her
standards right as well but right now if
she does stay on D3 with the c Pawn
maintains this pin on the G file how do
you defend the bishopone F6 if you try
to go King h8 get out of Dodge I will
take take Queen to F4 Queen takes H6 is
coming followed by root 2 G4 which is
coming as well you're getting checkmated
absolutely right if you're trying to go
to the other side it's even worse I take
and I actually Checkmate you in one
immediately right so
um how do you defend you want to go
[ __ ] P5 I'll take that thank you very
much I'll take on H6 I'm going to get uh
the Checkmate that I
Queen takes C5 Queen to G7 is coming
there's no way you can defend against
that so serious for black what happened
no no it's not dangerous it's completely
losing okay
it's finished at this point there's no
way to defend oh my goodness if you go
King to H7 I still take and the same
thing Queen to F4 you still cannot
defend on H6 right
so actually C takes Z3 just finishes the
game on the spot because at least you're
going to be
a peace dollar I'm going to take on F6
not only that but I'm also checkmating
you after that because Bishop takes H6
is coming there's just too many pieces
swarming around the black king and
there's no Defenders Yes actually all of
them four pieces
why not exactly it's uh Rochelle is
learning a very awkward lesson in these
Sicilians many many times I've watched
Gary Kasparov and other great Sicilian
players almost always Anastasia and I
mean almost always in these positions
that we have on my board they choose the
square E8
and you think to yourself well what's
that all about well very often as we saw
in the game there is this E5 there are
these moments where you capture on F4
and then the Rook is very nicely played
on placed on the e-file now if you look
at the current game position
and imagine that after all of these
moves that were played there was The
Rook was on E8
you could also play Queen d8 Bishop d8
Bishop E7 Rook takes E4 so this was
misplaced it's misplaced on d8 and you
know it takes
um you know hundreds and hundreds of
games and looking at games of the top
players where you see these same
familiar patterns recurring Time and
Time Again The Rook is actually better
placed on E8 than d8 a bad a difficult
lesson for Rochelle but as Christian is
mentioning C takes D3
The Bishop's trapped in the middle of
the board you know everybody is
anticipating that we'll be able to play
Bishop E5 but as Christian pointed out
takes Bishop takes H6 how you did the
gonna defend the mate on G7 and I think
we're going to see by the way a
repetition in Fabiano's
exactly perhaps we can see oh the shake
of hands in this one sorry yes um
Fabiano probably will make a draw phone
yes yes and then he will have that half
point lead
for
going into the last round Bishop to F3
Rook a five Bishop to D1 Rook to A1
this seems to have been so Sam Franklin
actually uh sacrificed an exchange yes
for the bishop as well as the pawn on A2
and it looks like just a very well
played draw yes
yes they knew the theory great job
yes
he didn't really need to push too much
in this game he just has a really great
position before the last round he needs
just to make a draw and then ask
question
would you like to join me on the first
place or you are fine with also with the
drawing your second position in the
tournament they received Frank the chief
Arbiter what he did by the way is he
turned to Leonard and said hey is this a
draw okay so Frank says okay okay good
good good good so we do have three draws
and one win in the open section the Von
eronian has won uh three draws in the
other games uh a Wonder Liang versus
darush that's ongoing and Sam sevion
what about Hans yes exactly what about
Hans and let's pick it up where we left
it the
um the black king just made a beeline
straight towards uh the B-2 pawn and
white has said look I'm busted my only
chance is you know you go ahead and do
your worst against my king my only
chance is to get the pawn uh on H7 and
this Pawn on H6 going well let's have a
quick look-see yes check yes and I'm
looking for those wonderful double Rook
Checkmate setups so let's go check right
before and uh where's
yeah maybe I can go Rook F7 and once you
take on H7 I can take on B2
can I oh that's a nice one and uh you
enjoy the fact that for the moment we
have the spin I don't know maybe white
still has some ideas but and now you
arrest
seven if you say that by the way arrest
yes wow you're under arrest you're not
moving you're gonna rest in my room
that's what it's lost for black now
because your king just goes to G6 and
I'm not in time to let's say promote my
apples oh my God I cannot believe it
that's unbelievable I was looking to I
was trying to create a trap exactly and
I fell for it but it's the other way
around the other way around you you
still win it's terrible yes I know I
hate that uh when I win I mean uh Rook
G1 uh let's take a look here yes who's
arresting whom so your king you know
like I've got these
that doesn't uh that doesn't check mate
at least we have a draw always always
always I just thought there was
something much more concrete no of
course in this exact moment
really interesting position I mean you
cannot really understand anything maybe
just three and if I take on between
immediately
let's say again I'm losing the word
no now if you take on P2 at least I kind
of it's a defend my phone on H7 very
useful all the Well Done indeed
or something I don't know something like
that yes well I will probably
sidestep but okay this I I think you're
on the right track here uh just in this
moment so how can we do it let's just
say we lose a tempo for example
but then we go to the same position yes
when you arrested me last time no no I
don't want to go there again yes not
again no no no no and I don't have time
to play something for the group G7 you
just will take with the pawn and you'll
promote I think last just a second okay
can you just see is it the difference
yeah the arrest happened when the King
was far away okay right yes you see how
you scared me yesterday
very very well so how how is this okay I
took a pawn ah
you go for all and you go all the way up
here
and yes but you can take with the King
yes and then
it's another no I I don't know yeah I'm
looking for something a lot more simpler
for Hans Hans is thinking it over is is
Sam in some time trouble yes he was
actually and it remains some moves I
think a couple of moves until the time
control and then he gets Hans has 20
minutes to think I see for sure about
his position refresh my board I've got
oh I got blue 40.
so he's made uh did Sam uh and back over
to you Christian as we have guests in
studio we uh do have Levon aronian it's
been 12 rounds but finally you got the
victory in the tournament
congratulations Lavon how do you feel
right now
I'm Rel relieved because I think
you know not winning for so long can
damage here
mental system
uh so I don't think it was a game of
highest quality but
at this moment I will take any kind of
win absolutely especially going into the
final day against Fabiano caruana one of
your good friends but such a critical uh
game for the standings now let's talk
about your game against elshon take us
through the critical moment yeah I I've
played this line with black myself
against Lanier uh in American Cup and of
course it's a difficult line to play for
black uh very strategical and I think
Lanier played C3 also against me which
another game you had to win you were in
a must win situation it's a very tricky
move
have to say because there's no C3 yeah
because it's basically white is waiting
and you can't really play for C5 because
then DC this uh yeah it's a bit too
early yeah there's 94 stuff is
very very dangerous from black
so you need to make a useful move and
you actually don't have yeah I think I
also played Princess seven I don't
remember yeah
we don't see it right here or maybe I
played A6 something like this yeah
and yeah I thought the G5 is a bit
premature now this Knight F1 looks very
very bad for black and what is the plan
behind this maneuver uh what I want to
do is play Knight G3 and you know
whenever I get the chance to just plant
something on H5 so get the night out and
then get age 39-ish too and or Bishop D3
and then try to put something to change
yeah the lights for the Bishops and get
the Knight to H5 yeah and I felt that
this is I mean this is logical that he
tries to but it should be a bad position
just a bad end game in the position yeah
I I think I just made some mistakes
around here yes
my understanding of this maybe is not
good so I I felt this is a very good
position for why but the computers I see
yeah but it's unclear from a practical
perspective it does feel like you have
more space more weaknesses to work with
yeah so Bishop yeah I thought that
Bishop E7 there has to be a move maybe I
should have tried for rookie C3 I saw
this in Knight B8 and I felt uh Rook B3
and Rook C7
and I I was thinking mainly about Bishop
D3 here but then I wasn't sure I can
break through if he just castles castle
Yeah Yeah
it's it's indeed Pleasant because in
this structure when you take on G6 you
can remove the Knight let's say 92 and
play G4 it's very very pleasant and
you'll start to play with H4 this G4
move is very typical for the structure
right inside and try to get to H6 and it
really uh cuts the Black Knights out of
the play yeah but but he didn't see the
exact breakthrough no I thought it might
end in a draw you know
so I saw this Rook uh B3 Knight B6 uh
but you know from distance I blundered
that if I take on C6 so Bishop C6 Rook
C6 a rook C6 BC Bishop B4 okay this is a
beautiful chippo this is for uh yes sir
of course
but uh yeah then I take them three yeah
yeah but the problem with this line that
after Bishop before move num 22.
he takes takes
King D7 Knight D2 this all looks good
but this bishop C2 is probably
giving him enough time to play no more
Knight B3 well if you go Knight yeah
Knight F1 then Rook B8 it's very precise
and 93 A5 yeah and he's in time yeah and
you cannot take on B6 because B2 is
hanging at the end yeah you're actually
just losing this one very nice so yeah
you decide to go for it yeah I I knew
that this is
probably nothing but well definitely
some pressure it seems like yeah at
least confirmed by 700k
yeah I saw that uh after Knight B2 I was
planning to play uh
I was thinking to play Rook A1 but I
thought this is probably equal
kind of Rook gate and then it chases my
Rook with very precise play yeah yeah
okay it rugby seven maybe right C4
things of this nature so maybe I
shouldn't have taken on S7 yeah
seems like Bishop to C3 was the best I
saw this move but I felt that you know
if he goes Rook B8 I got a seven I've
assume
ah so Knight B2 takes takes away six
yeah yeah I didn't believe in this
somehow I thought black is too active
but maybe
yeah probably a wrong assessment from
from me yeah and the Knights don't seem
to have a clear path to get back into
the game so yeah I was a bit worried
that this is just going to end in a draw
as well from afar this is not easy to
assess for sure all right and he took on
A7 and yeah I got lucky here and I
managed to play 92 and yeah this is
already you maintain your Pawn he
doesn't get to it and a nice conversion
can see you Levon congratulations and
important victory for you tomorrow with
the black pieces against a player you
know so well Fabiano caruana how are you
going to approach that one
I think the goal is uh you know just to
stay solid and see what uh
you know game dictates it's not really
I'm I'm not having a great term but you
know last round has its own
rules absolutely always a pleasure to
play spoilers also if you're having a
bad event you might as well try to mess
up the other players congratulations
live on Good Guys any questions no our
congratulations Lavon and we'll be
looking forward to your game tomorrow
and here is our update Anastasia with a
few games
has finished his game in the draw so he
is sole leader the Soul Leader with
eight points and prayer options just
have a point behind him Daniel Dominguez
with seven points on the third position
very strong consumption that was six and
a half and we still have some games
underway so we'll see depending on the
results that there will be some
difference but in the meanwhile it's
sort of like crazy crazy things kind of
happening between Jennifer and Arena and
it's sort of like the point is being
thrown back and forth like a hot potato
between the two players is some very
strange Decisions by Arena right here
Bishop takes E5 she decided to play the
move Rook E8 and then Queen F3 and I
thought well okay white is a pawn down
but wait a minute you know after H5 he's
not that easy you know I mean it's could
be good it could be beautiful especially
with Jennifer yes it was supposed to
color Bishops on G6 yes yes yes you get
to the king so sorry Christian well I
would assume Queen to G7 has to be
played Queen to G7 has to be played but
then okay I mean I've got a weakness
that I can gnaw on I mean you know this
this pawn and you know on a good day I
prefer white yes I mean because the
extra Pawn is B6 and that's not paying
playing a role so we get right here and
I'm thinking okay Jennifer
is really turned things around she's
probably doing well she blundered a
whole Bishop
Bishop A4 Arena took it and after Queen
F7 The Rook is not hanging really I mean
it was just so blunt right it's just
like this double this blind spot yes and
I'm sure when Jennifer Jennifer was
thinking I pushed the queen away from
The Rook The Rook is unprotected and
then she played H5 she could probably
resigns a last chance and Bishop E2 on
the board but she's now a full piece
down this blows the standings wide open
exactly yeah I mean Talia is winning as
well she's going to be in the same
position as Jennifer with eight points
the only explanation for this moment is
just that everybody is so tired also the
it's a it's a game of nerves right now
so yes so probably she just I mean
simply blunder because
it was a blind spot I mean we all we all
have these blind moments where again I
mean in your mind you're thinking to
yourself Queen F7 is overwhelming yes
you want to believe that Queen F7 check
will win the game you got a problem you
just want to kick the queen out of the
way and then Queen F7 wins yes so you go
Bishop A4 and in your mind's eye you've
played Queen F7 and you're taking the
Rook with Jack and Maiden yes you get
here and it's oopsie Daisy big big big
shocking turn of events but Christian uh
back to you at Gaston Studio we have the
leader of the open section Fabiano
caruana with us Fabi uh another draw
another step towards the championship
you're going into the final round with a
half a point lead how do you feel right
now
yeah today was good I was under a lot of
pressure
the opening didn't really go the way I
wanted
so and then the draw was a good result
uh and there was also good that Ray
didn't didn't catch up
were you worried that Christopher is
going to play a loose game given his
past results yeah he sometimes plays
very well and sometimes very uh
carelessly so today he played a very
whiskey line but uh I mean it's supposed
to be a bit dubious for white this line
it's very tricky because the black can
lose by force but I mean once I saw like
the time and he Christopher was playing
so quickly and seems to know the
position well I I didn't feel like um
like he would lose that game I even
thought that maybe
I mean if anyone's going to win it's
more likely to be Christopher after the
opening uh so yeah overall it was a good
day uh I don't know if Sam is like at
this game I just can't comprehend sounds
needs to be a bit worse at this point
this is what we have right now yeah I
just don't understand this position I
mean
you'd rather be black yes
but I don't know what's going on I I
mean it's it's strange to say black is
like what is worse I mean it's either a
draw or it's winning for black yeah uh
which like I would assume it's a draw
usually these things turn into a draw
but
um
or maybe not
we don't know I mean you have to be very
I mean that King is in a rather
precarious position position on the
other hand he is
two Rooks aren't going to mate the King
Alone
uh he's winning H7 I don't know but uh
as long as he doesn't win it's uh it's
kind of okay for me absolutely I don't
think he'll win and you mentioned that
you were under some pressure out of the
opening it felt that way as well with
your opening Choice were you trying to
keep some chances alive in case
Christopher is is not it's playing loose
well not really I mean I I wanted to
keep chances alive but uh you know
getting a worse position from the
opening is not really the way to do it
um I just
played a lot I'm not super familiar with
I've used to play a long time ago but I
just thought like I played Knight C7
recently and I didn't expect any choice
no no after instead of G6 the other main
line is Knight C7
and I played it recently and I thought
maybe he'll be ready for this so I
decided okay I'll just play G6 I tried
to remember my decision over the board
this was my Kansas preparation from
2016. yeah it was over the board and
trying to remember
but failing to I remember I played
against Peter speedler here and he
played Knight G5 E6 D3
I played I think Bishop G7 he played a
H4
or the first night by G4 and then uh was
it so I played B6 or Castle I don't
remember
B6 stage for something like the b6h4
yeah yeah I was losing this game I mean
he came this was a brilliant idea at the
time
um from what I understand computers just
say it's a complete uh nonsense now but
at the time it was yeah it was based on
this exchange stack which uh like white
takes on C5 and after a more V12 or H I
don't remember exactly and the white
takes on C5 but take everything
these type of positions yeah I think it
was this maybe not with agency
yeah it was probably with H6
um and here I couldn't I mean Bishop G7
I was trying to remember because there's
like this move Queen C4 and I couldn't
figure it out yeah my db4 castle I was
like okay I'm gonna lose upon it I'm
going to regret this decision I played
the more solid move instead E6
kind of just accepting a slightly worse
position
but at least I'm solid I guess
but I wasn't happy I mean his moves are
so easy here he just everything he did
it's just so so natural rookie one king
F1
and I played this move F5 I don't know I
was a bit worried about it but I didn't
see what else to do and I thought this
is kind of forcing his hand he can play
A3 he can take on D5 but he you'll want
to do something because I might at some
some stage want to play at four I mean
he has to make a move I thought E3 is
also moved but then my db4 is probably
I'm sorry a night I'd see before
uh Queen D7 Rook D7 and I thought this
equalizes
you have some problems with these yeah
some problems with A2 as well probably
not A2 but D3 is very difficult I mean
he might have to play an id5 95 and then
B2 is hanging so he's unlikely to get an
advantage here uh and so
I was actually a bit surprised after A3
94 I was expecting Queen C4
I wasn't sure what this was Queen C4
it's like yeah F4 I wanted but I wasn't
your gf4
because if I take twice then E3 yeah
this I this I like it was too chaotic
for me to understand but I also
understand why he didn't go for it so if
you take Queen F7 is that the idea I
guess I guess so we have seven again H5
I mean it's very risky of course to us
but but I really thought he would want
to win today uh so I was kind of
expecting a sharper choice because Queen
D5 hadn't Queen E7 I didn't feel like
like I should be really worse I mean
tiny bit but and I think you guys enter
this very forced line
uh which the computer by the way was
recommending all these moves but it
doesn't seem like it worse yeah if he
doesn't play Bishop before I thought I
might be better
like I don't know some move Bishop E1
and I play like King F7 okay he always
has Bishop B4 I guess but
um but if he doesn't at some point play
this move then I'll play Rook B6 King E6
maybe at some stage because I always
have this Knight D2 trick which uh if I
can get King E6 and Rook B7 that 92
becomes a thread and his Rooks are stuck
so that's why he played Bishop B4 and
then I still thought I'm
rather like slightly unpleasantly worse
great yeah it's a bit unpleasant
for example at this moment like I
thought was kind of clever if I if I
play another move for example
I play rookie six it was my first
attention he takes takes Rook C1 I
didn't see how to completely equalize
this position like A4 Rook
um
Rook C6
Rook D6 Rook C8
Rook A6 and Rook G at I thought this was
unpleasant still a complicated position
but after Bishop to F3 it seemed like
you guys went into a drawish line yeah
Bobby we'll let you go get your rest and
we'll see you tomorrow in the
championship round
indeed uh good luck Fabi to you and
tomorrow's ultimate round we have seen
uh a big big result as Arena crash our
eight-time U.S Champion comes today a
half a point behind and defense yes
Jennifer you with the black pieces to
take a half a point lead going into the
last round game and Jennifer must just
feel terrible exactly she just wants to
run away from this game it's just too
painful it's very painful because she's
somehow crazily enough Arena had allowed
her right back into the game after move
30 and here she just had this illusion
uh this illusion that Queen F7 was
winning for her all she had to do was
get rid of the queen she did it with
Bishop A4 only to realize she's we
should probably go to bed in his game
because we will see a result as well as
well Talia is closing in on another
victory her 15 year old guys wow
and you there is no way to defend
against it it's a Checkmate as well as
if you take the bishop then you'll win
the queen this one is over guys yes it
seems like it's over
as well beg him only 10 seconds on her
clock but it's not about time anymore
it's just that position is really bad
truly you cannot do anything right now
you know exactly
and the game
if you play a few moves you know it was
just it was going through my mind there
for a moment that winning five in a row
in the U.S Championship is really
extraordinary who else had ever
accomplished that and I forgot about the
Bobby Fisher Price for for that briefest
of moments Bobby Fischer famously going
11. that was a bit more than five zero
yeah exactly and begum looks it's
another roller coaster player uh begum
uh in this in this event she's she's one
on a streak and she's lost on streaks
yeah and she lost a lot of steam in the
last couple of rounds she won that
important matchup against Megan Lee
followed it up with another Victory
against ashfrita but yesterday's match
with the white pieces against Jennifer
you just that hurt was Soul Crush that
hurt because she was in contention still
at that point with a victory she could
happen
two years and then you just you just
stay and very slowly slowly you you go
uh pardon me just don't stay after
looking reaches
and yeah your king can't come to B2 but
but you've got a majority yeah F5 and
you you eventually okay industry okay
and that is a win that is just a stone
cold wind but my goodness Arena crush
and it was really sad I sorry I wanted
to say that Jennifer had actually gotten
very uh nicely outplayed out of the
opening Arena had a huge Advantage
probably close to winning and right here
in my opinion things had turned positive
for Jennifer she played the right move
and she just had to follow up with the
most direct move you can imagine opening
up or trying to open up this diagonal
for for the bishop or crazy there's just
six weaknesses yeah something like
Bishop could I'll take the pawn thank
you yeah I mean we we do understand but
on a good day I could plant the bishop
on E6 and white will be for choice and
Jennifer just had a terrible illusion
and was just a piece down for nothing
went down in a blaze of glory or so to
speak I don't know maybe she somehow was
in this kind of fighting mood that she
should win no matter what or something
like that maybe she's kind of such an
attitude throughout the whole tournament
she pushes herself oftentimes to the
extreme sometimes it can backfire if
especially if the tournament is too long
and like you cannot have the same energy
to play every game where they set it to
sometimes it's too hard you know
sometimes you're even coach can advise
you to make a draw you know play Pace
normally and if it's a George that's
accepted it's a draw it's another
approach to try to win like every game
and fight in every game but yeah I mean
it can be sometimes dangerous I saw this
extreme
approach by Hans Neiman like he'd come
in and he was just like win or lose it's
the same thing today I don't care no
draw yeah I wanted to play for the win
said Hans Neiman and sometimes you just
you just fall flat on your face when you
ask too much you you force that because
you're ready for this type of outcome as
well and I think we already had another
result that is abrahamian defeated
Rochelle Wu yeah I saw her position with
Veruca yes yeah but it was a rook up but
somehow okay we we had left it more or
less let's say yes I just wanted to say
here yes in the next position I saw was
a white King on e4 and I was like how
did the how did White's King go from B1
to E4 well it was the extra Rook that
did it and here she goes and somehow the
white king cost took her a couple of
Pawns but this is the position yes where
tatv said okay look I'm a rook Rook up
and he went waiting position and she did
in indeed win this game and we're
expecting again that Talia will win and
so that will set up a situation where
Arena will have a half a point lead over
two players who both play each other
exactly will play against Jennifer you
in the last round and uh
exactly and our leaders with Christian
in studio Irene I came to the studio
yesterday and we were discussing your
head to head that you were behind zero
two and you said I have the chance to
improve that score and you came today
with such an aggressive stance you
played the delayed benoni and you got
what you wanted how do you feel right
now yeah I feel really good I mean
obviously if that's uh that's the result
I was aiming for today I mean it's hard
to understate uh it's hard to overstate
the importance of this game you know
when you're half a point behind there's
only two rounds left
and um you know what I've learned over
the years I think I kind of alluded to
that yesterday is that you can't expect
anyone else to do your work for you you
know if you want to win the tournament
and you have a head-to-head battle like
you have to take your chances there
because hoping that your opponent like
someone else will get a draw off of them
or slow them down
um yeah that's not that's not productive
right so I kind of came in trying to uh
to do this myself today and yeah my
opening
um I think was uh was was good for the
moment it was indeed and you got into a
very nice position after she decided to
take on E6 and change the structure were
you still familiar with this position
yeah I was familiar with this position
but after Bishop E2 like this is where I
had like a 15 minute think after a
knight C6 castles
I first think of the game and actually I
was pretty happy with what I came up
with just like
um you know simple developing move V6 so
you just have to kind of figure out how
you want your pieces to be overall this
game I mean yeah it was definitely
always
um like black in Black's favor
um but there were some moments of course
that made it like technically tricky to
win we can keep going forward the
strategical details that you were aiming
for in this position yeah I mean well
here's the thing I mean I got everything
in with like bonus tempos in this game
because I got to put I mean 91 certainly
cannot be you know the way to play this
position
um you know I got to have my knight on
D4 then white spent another Tempo with
the bishop on D3 so there were two
tempos to get the Knight to C2 where
it's not even clear what it does
differently from F3
um and then Bishop B2 to D3 so basically
I just got up you know fantastic
position and
um I had time to put my pieces on all
their best squares and start the play on
the king side
and here yeah I mean E5
um I don't know I decided that it was
time for this move I was looking at
things like Knight B8 to C6 here as well
like I don't know I thought maybe I
should try to bring another Knight to D4
but you know ultimately y went for E5
was because I wanted to play against the
light squared Bishop
um F5 yeah I see the computer sewing
this move you know honestly I didn't
even think this was tactically possible
it kind of looks like it just gives away
a pawn right it probably is giving away
a pawn so yeah the computer goes from
like zero zero to like zero point minus
six it's a very hard move to play I mean
I would say almost impossible for white
to like you know figure out now is the
time for me to go F5 I mean Knight D5 is
a very natural move by white and you
also have such nice support of the night
on D4 with the pawn Steel on C5 and E5
yeah so she went for this position which
is kind of what I was expecting so I
took and here I really thought like I
was close to winning and
um I felt like it was a little uh unfair
that she had had this amazing G3 trick
you know a couple of moves down I mean
come on like you know you think that she
just you know blunders right Rook F4 and
then to figure out that she has G3 I
mean wow that's like I mean I did not
see G3 and thank God that I you know
thought for a little bit before that's
what you missed yeah yeah I did not see
that there was G3 like when I was
calculating all of this and I decided I
mean I already kind of thought I was
winning because if she goes Bishop E3
instead of uh King H1 then I just put
her in a pin with rookie eights and you
know she can't really get out of it yeah
like here there's just too much because
we have six point H4 so her you know um
so the pin wins but the fact that you
can go King age one and leave the back
rank open and then you just take a
bishop and she just goes to G3 it's a
kind of unusual idea I have to say right
like it's it's definitely possible to
miss that from a distance so once I
missed that okay I mean white uh black
is still better but obviously you're not
gonna win the game right away so I
decided to keep on playing
you know on these dark squares
um
yeah I mean I how do you regroup
yourself mentally at that point well
well it's fine I mean yeah there's G3
it's a trick uh you got to keep going I
mean you're still better you still got
the dark squares the B2 Pawn is falling
the bishop on C2 is not great
um but it really became like a technical
thing right which of course you know was
not my plan uh from the outset and I
think you know she played uh quite well
interesting decision to go Queen E2 and
Sack the pawn like right here Queen E2
was not a very obvious move right that
she I mean I thought okay I was
expecting maybe bishop takes E5 but I
think probably her decision is the right
one yeah it is indeed yeah this was a
quite a good practical Choice by her
because the problem is for me to win
this position I gotta get rid of the
dark squared Bishop
yeah if I can trade then it's over but
the bishop and F4 is such a strong
Defender and it just wasn't uh it wasn't
so easy at all and it felt like she was
getting her initiative as well going on
the king side yeah I mean it's like she
can't do so much I mean unless I really
decide to go overboard but let's move
rookie eight I mean I guess I mean
um whoa whoa that does not expect such
an evaluation rookie I mean I'm trying
to keep the Rooks on the board so here H
yeah H5
wow well I definitely didn't think I was
you know gonna be ever in trouble in
this position
um but yeah of course this H5 idea I was
seeing in fact you know like a move like
even before you know like if she goes in
fact right before uh Queen F3 I was
looking at age five here but the
difference is now I take with the rook
and then I get to play Queen F3 Queen E7
just in time and then I'm actually good
right so I was seeing these ideas but
yeah Queen F3 of course is stronger
because she makes me take with my bishop
and the e-file is closed and then she
goes H5 wow Checkmate going on if you
take it with the Rooks yeah that's
amazing though I mean to think that
black could be worse here like from what
well like I mean even if Queen G7 what
to go for these changes yeah what was
wrong with like Queen G7 I mean oh is it
is there F7 H6 H6 maybe no I think no
it's okay I just like that I just invade
on the light Square it's amazing and her
Bishop actually comes into the game
I mean I it was it was technically
difficult as part like I just felt like
of course I wasn't expecting to be worse
like in this line and I mean I tried the
problem is if I allowed The Rook trade
like if we go back to the Rook trade
and like let's say it would have just
played uh Bishop takes E5 instead of
rookie eight okay yeah like I mean I
just thought that this you know very
closely it's very closer quality like
because the truth is the B Pawn is
irrelevant and she's going to be playing
on the king side with H5 like why should
she lose this position she's not yeah
yeah this one seems very simplified yeah
and you decided to keep but that that
yeah you know I saw these ideas I had to
check for that because actually one last
thing can we go back for one second
because in this position when the queen
was on E2 I also had to check the move
Queen D1 you know just in case right
because I now I can't take with a bishop
but again now I can take with the rook
and I survive right it's like I was
definitely aware of these ideas and I
mean yeah she just forgot that the queen
on the diagonal was still protecting The
Rook right so you think it was just a
blunder yeah oh yeah I think she just
she just didn't
um she kind of thought she was pulling
the queen away and queen F7 wins The
Rook or something and then she just
forgot that the queen is on the same
diet I actually realized when she made
the move or after she made the move you
know I honestly didn't like look at her
facial expressions too much at that
point I mean I knew that it was a
blunder and the queen was holding the
Rook so
um yeah I mean I think she realized it
pretty pretty quickly and of course
after that there's no way she gets you
around yeah my Bishop is so nice now
it's like defending everything so well
and you converted nicely Irina
congratulations uh good spot for you
you're going into the last round with
half a point lead but two competitors
playing against each other potential uh
to score a victory in that one how are
you going to approach tomorrow's game
against one of your good friends and
Rivals yeah I understand I know right
you know it's funny because I'm playing
three U.S women's champions in a row
yeah actually right I didn't I realized
that I've got Nazi Jennifer and now Anna
and wow I see I've played a lot of games
against Anna over the years
um and this is only classical games yeah
classical right so
well I feel good I mean you know in the
tournament you got to do your job right
that's the first thing so
um that's what I'm gonna do tomorrow
again you know just do my job with the
white pieces try to play good chess and
try to close things out guys any
questions congratulations Arena that was
really quite the tumultuous game and uh
it's something we expected we expected
fireworks and uh it delivered so good
luck tomorrow Arena thank you for coming
to the last round game with uh a half a
point lead and I'm looking at the game
Italia and she's just played a really
good move I like this move very much
against begum I mean she's completely
winning but now this move Queen D3 makes
Black's life a lot easier yes because
she gets to go Queen F1 check if you
move your king to G4 I go and I pick up
A2 if you move your king to E4 I go to
G2 and I go to A2 and that's exactly
what Talia has spotted and Talia is
going to go in tomorrow's game
half a point behind Jennifer and she's
going to Hope Anna zatowski holds and
she could win and play off alone and
she's on a five-game winning I know it's
just great I mean wow mood you have
normally when you have exactly actually
now with King Deford I don't know I
thought about Queen G2 also like small
trick to win this
yes no the queen too and yeah I mean if
if King 425
even better I know I'm looking how to
win the roof but 25 is better yeah
exactly King E4 we expect Queen G2 and
then uh Hardy hand clasp as we would say
by the way uh in the open section
won his game uh same as 11 Iranian today
they after the peaceful draw yesterday
they well again the defending Champion
um Wesley so kind of well having a
terrible event let's just put it that
way winning with the black piece is
winning in the penultimate round again
it's one of those things that really
improves your mood
tremendously and uh on the screens we
can see Thalia just finished uh and
Megan they finished their game and wins
the thiefs I really lost this track
exactly fifth game in the row and she
jumps on the second place with eight
points right
um crazy game still going on between uh
Sam sevion and and Hans and I like this
evolution of Fabi we said that in this
kind of positions normally it's a draw I
mean he didn't want to calculate but I
like his assessment you know like yeah
I'm like I was like scratching my head
too it's like really really uh should
this be a draw because it's such an
important uh game for the the the
players here Sam Savion he came into the
round found with a plus two undefeated
score kind of thinking you know things
go well I could go plus three I think
there is a secret it's some kind of a
trap with Rook H7 maybe Rook H6 what
what what uh
yes like you exchange it we just saw
Rook G6 and it's white to play yes if
it's right to play Rook H7
here moving to the rookendigo it's
completely stupid because I just see my
king on B3 and then I think maybe I can
yeah win this one no yeah it's some sort
of a race I think I have a big big
Pawn as well the F Pawn so let's go F4
F4 it's a race it's a five and then I
get F6 going and King G5 Rook H3 I think
I'm just in time to sacrifice wow but
it's kind of interesting oh it
absolutely yeah I just thought that it's
good it's funny well the king is cut off
right yeah so it's not it's not so easy
for white to just escort the pawn oh
yeah I can work H7 yeah maybe you have
to find the only moves now because
actually what I want is just King A1 and
take some parts yeah no no no no you're
fine don't you just want King A1 and
yes why not no okay just have one maybe
okay okay seven then I go like that's
okay
ah you take the phone oh come on you
know what I'm going to do why did you
have to ask take the pawn yes and take
give up the rook and I think one of
these pawns is gonna force you to give
up The Rook uh is
is Sam saving himself uh perhaps this
last move was not the most precise what
was the last move Rook G6 Oh you mean
yes
last move was not precise maybe he
should have taken the other Pawn the
pawn on A5 ah actually yes he could do
it
and Rook takes A5 and half maybe after
the elimination of the Pawn on betu two
connected passers but I mean these
positions are so difficult to calculate
right right and no just continue taking
Pawns in fact really take on F2 yes keep
going sorry keep taking Palms yes right
yeah because it makes sense the problem
is and this is something that we looked
at if you go into the other line with
Rook 2 A2 too many pawns yes and I have
these ideas that we were discussing King
G5 you take on B2 and then I take back
on B2 you take on H7 and I trap The Rook
with Bishop G7 arrest we we were always
falling for this this type of ideas
and it does seem like white is in time
and
yes uh but Rook G6 was probably an error
then I think it was really pleased with
this idea okay to show Rook H6 moves
sometimes you think about beauty of
Chess you don't really care that much
even if you win the game or not okay
this is just now from hans's apartment
from Sam's Point of View he's he's put
his Bishop on G7 he's put his Rook on h8
yes he's put everything he's had into
winning the pawn on H7
showing some nervousness as he's
realizing maybe in a key line that he
analyzed It featuring your movement H6
something's amiss uh for him and he's uh
he's having a remorse I want to say
about this move Rook G6 but I think uh
not quite yet
uh let's just remind our viewers where
we are with the ladies yes so Irina
crash grab the first place like eight
and halfway south of 12 now
ninth trophy if you don't mind exactly
and Jennifer is now on the second
position she ties for the first second
place together with Silas Cervantes who
just won her game against beg him
I guess fifth game in a row that's just
amazing yes and Chase was a Christian
with Christiano
Talia five games in a row five wins I
mean you must be on cloud nine right now
no I am I am extremely happy
um again today it was very interesting
not only is the game of friend but she's
obviously a very strong player and I was
playing with black too so this just for
me it's a great result and how did you
look at this game were you thinking
about uh you being in a must win
situation given that you have to catch
up with the leaders so I think
technically I was in a must win
situation I was trying not to think
about it too hard just in case that
let's say I got an equal position I
wouldn't mess it up trying to fight for
something else
um but I'm glad that in the game I did
have a lot of opportunities and
um the positions were actually complex
so they gave me some chances and I was
very happy when I realized that let's
talk about the game it was quite an
interesting uh grew felt and that is
your specialty uh Talia tell us a bit
about this position the thing is I think
it's all
soldiers I think she plays it looked
like as well so I wasn't so sure if this
was my best option but I was pleased
with the position I had I wasn't
entirely sure
um how to handle it but I'm not used to
seeing the position with the Knight only
2 and the pawn on e4 and I feel like
that's perhaps a slightly better and I
don't need two and the point on e4 like
based on some transpositions but yeah
um so I thought that this would be fine
and overall the way that the game
continued I felt like I was doing okay
especially after F4
um I I felt like my position was
beginning to get comfortable in her
pieces I wasn't super sure where they
were going to go and after Knight F3
Rook T8 Queen E2
I felt like my position was really nice
so
um this is an interesting moment after
okay one uh you know sometimes
you are thinking during the game and
you're like okay if I win this game I
have to explain my move and that's a big
problem
we're not putting any extra pressure how
do I explain H6
um no the thing is that I honestly just
had no idea what to do and I really
enjoyed how my pieces were in this
position because the bishop 185 stops
94.95 ideas so originally I wanted to
play something like Bishop to H3 but I
didn't want to allow that Plan 94 Knight
C5 right it does make sense because it's
a good Bishop but at the same time I
wasn't so sure if I wanted to allow
something like take States and 94 or
even 95 94 something like that but
um
yeah so I was happy with how my pieces
were right now and I thought okay maybe
she wants to play Knight g594
um and that's one of the other two
houses made you finite so you wanted to
stop that right H6 it's just I honestly
had no idea what to do in that position
and here I felt like I needed to also
just have some sort of action in the
position I was worried that I would let
whatever Advantage I had slip but and
why to stabilize get the Knight to E5
and things like that so Green Bay five
was a move that I consider I don't think
I can trap the queen
in any way it almost looks like after
Bishop D3 Queen before I may have
something but I don't think I do
um like she can
um probably just maybe get the night out
of the way yeah crazy three back so for
example that's a bit annoying
um
but after a Quimby fire I wasn't so sure
what I was going to do probably Knight
D5 I was thinking either one of them
um and then just see how how the game
was just a normal video game position
right after this one but she played this
move rook fd1 and allowed you this very
nice transition attacking the queen
placed the queen on a bad square and now
tie this idea of Knight to D3 and pick
up the exchange if she goes Rook to C1
how fast did you spot this idea I had
this idea in mind I just wasn't sure
which variation of it was the best
um
so originally I was thinking about
instead of Bishop C2 playing C5 right
away but then I felt like the bishop on
C2 can block the C file in case hero
goes there and
um The Rook you know it's a lot better
than the one on F1 so I might as well
put it there absolutely and it was the
right decision indeed and it just felt
like her pieces went
um super coordinated for example her
Bishop doesn't have many squares to go
to and I was just hoping I wasn't sure
what was happening but I was just hoping
that you know there would be something
for me and I think tactically there is
after this sequence and I think her last
chance was to go to A4 did you consider
this move I didn't consider at all but I
assume that after Knight takes it's like
85 and try to play this position I see
away the in in the game when I had the
Knight on D3 I do have some might be two
ideas and I was considering them yes but
it's funny how here there's no detail
yes as well might be to probably the
best movie in the position
still black has a pretty significant
Advantage uh at this point but after
this movement I tweet to you fully took
control of the game and I never let go
of the advantage Talia congratulations
um five wins in a row and tomorrow
you're actually facing Jennifer you how
are you going to approach this game is
that a must-win game are you playing for
that Championship are you starting to
dream yeah I think at first you know
especially because last year I didn't
have such a great score I finished like
seventh something along those lines um I
was just hoping to get top three in this
event but now my chances get more and
more realistic by the round so I'll just
see what happens
um obviously I want to win
um but so did Jennifer yesterday in the
interview so I have to be careful with
um how I handle things
um but yeah it would be amazing if I can
win guys any questions oh
congratulations
wow they already made big news you know
literally but I really like how Thalia
was coming every day she was I'm glad
I'm happy today I'm extremely happy I
mean it's like I want three games in a
row I feel good yeah okay all the best
of luck for you tomorrow I mean you
deserve where you should be now and it's
really interesting to see the fight
between YouTube Jennifer and Salem
absolutely really good like tomorrow
well done tell you and just to uh yeah
let's just review the standings
understandings once again Arena crashes
on the first visit
eight and a half points only half a
point
um ahead of two players Jennifer you and
Tyler Cervantes that they both have
eight points right Alice is still
playing I was still playing yes and
maybe she has some chances yeah it's
awesome to catch maybe this field or
stay a little bit close to them uh so
Rihanna has seven points as you can see
and it's important that Arena crash will
play tomorrow with Sanders while
Jennifer you will play against Thailand
everything is still possible and nobody
knows who will be the champion and
that's the great thing it truly is
really setting setting up for a dramatic
final they're just as in the open
section another dramatic final round
we've got two games uh going on but our
current standings
is still leading with eight points still
keeps only half upon distance from Ray
Robinson but you can see that linear
Domingos has also seven points he came
very close also to the leaders Wesley
saw with six and how he just won his
game and we still have the game game
between sam7 and Hans Neiman and
depending on the on this result we will
see who will join the leader leaders
group exactly yeah we just saw this move
F4 by Sam Sevilla what's going on here
I don't know it looks like uh they're
talking oh
maybe a draw they're talking you can
make a draw
somehow they want to they're discussing
something I hope they are discussing
something what's what's happening
something happened what's going on in
the current
what just happened yes let's see I see
that Hans is a little bit nervous he's
trying to say something perhaps there's
yes that the Knight is
no there were no miles in this position
it was like Paul sorry The King The King
yeah
something happened
yes wow oh you touched your king he's
saying that's your king but wait a
second I mean I mean that's not the same
explain with white you know his King is
on the chore
so I'm trying to understand no they
actually went into the operation that uh
you mentioned with Rook taxation yes
Rook text H6 I started to guess moves of
hands you know at the end of the
tournament okay so the the
Arbiter keeps starting the clock the
players keep stopping the clock
something is confusing yes really don't
know what happened but normally you have
to stop your clock and then you speak to
the Arbiter exactly well in any case uh
Hans is looking at the position after F4
now that was the line that we looked at
Anastasia is it a draw
um Christian I mean the the line we
looked at was pretty yes even yes yes
father said about it long time ago guys
it's a draw I don't want the one to
calculate it who will it go we were
looking for King takes B2
F5 let's keep going yeah B3 F6 I was
trying to maintain The Rook on the uh
so right now is Sam's sorry it's hans's
move yes let's see what happened yes and
then
what whoa
King
oh oh no
he was supposed to pick up a piece
and he broke and he broke the
yeah
I cannot believe what just happened oh
my God he just broke the king for some
reason and he put it back and now he's
telling him let's go outside and
what is this
that is hilarious I've never seen that
now he's trying to put the baby under
the table is is that what happened I
mean the cross is definitely upset about
it
you can't touch my game that's not yeah
[Laughter]
okay many players they have this Habit
to turn the piece right around a bad
terrible terrible I tried to imagine
that perhaps he just wanted to take
London if you did it you would be
shocked right but he was actually
motioning like let's go outside let's go
outside and then
but the crazy part was that when when uh
excuse me dude you're you're fiddling
with my king dude let's see again then
Sam kind of threw the king to B6 look at
his hands yes right now
and the cross has fallen out of the
king's side and then he's kind of just
threw the king to peace exit like what
let's go outside let's go outside
no he's got the cross in his hand it is
like fiddling oh my goodness dude what
is happening I don't know but somehow
oh that is I've never seen that that's
kind of funny
okay we need an explanation I I hope
after the end of this game we'll we'll
have it I hope I mean I mean he's I
think there are a few committees on the
way to start working right finally
finally the appeals committee has
something something must have happened
between these two guys when we were not
watching because they seemed distressed
both of them I I don't know what
happened but it seems like the nerves
the nerves the players are they seem to
be a little bit on the edge yeah they
are they are they definitely are you
know and by the way Sam uh sorry uh Hans
just took on B2 to the pawn
after all of that give me my king I mean
thank you let me take your bond with my
king king takes B2 oh my goodness so my
explanation is that Sam wanted to pick
up a piece off the board so he could
twiddle with it and somehow his King he
picked up the piece on the board why'd
you think the crows did well then it
popped out I don't know what happened
with with that but that was pretty
uh unusual I've never seen it actually
never ever actually what kind of penalty
can be for this type of yeah
take the king of your opponent like it's
almost an illegal move so I'm gonna
penalize you with an illegal move by
saying you know you did something that
you can't do you can't and I'll give you
I'm gonna give your opponent a reward
them with two minutes for bad
misbehavior but I have never seen this
one more look at what we just saw
because again this is unprecedented we
cannot see his little face right yes we
cannot see his whole face is that
correct I mean because I would love to
see his face right now
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's wrong like why do you why did you
do this why are you misbehaving you're
disrespectful U.S championships are
continued or something happening there's
something in the water man
in the same same vein as when we started
he repaired the king
that was kind it keeps touching the
kingdom and Hans is like dude man you
can't do it I mean leave my kingdom that
was impressive thing they just keep
playing okay
wow that's why sometimes you need to
have this press conferences with two
players you never know the press
conference so you get you you get the
double uh opinion right right right
right right
just on that note I remember the press
conference in the world championship in
New York
um Magnus had lost ah so we have also
faces
so he's stolen the king and now
that's the king Seb and Sam is like
still not not aware that oh it's a whole
King oh yeah oh yeah thank you
let's go and speak about it do you want
to speak about it he's he's telling him
let's go outside let's go outside why
should I go outside it's just my king
okay let's put it back and I will fix it
don't worry I'll just fix it I'm better
this is pretty funny guys
unbelievable nice this is the best I
think I ever seen it I don't know I
don't know
anybody knows this final look my heart
says it all like
hey man the dude was messing with my
king that that that's not permitted
people that fiddle with their pieces but
yeah I don't think that was it I think
there was much more to it than what we
know because we must answer these
questions and we must interview these
players because they have no idea what
just happened let's go out with them
right let's go so I remember the New
York uh world championship match Magnus
had lost Magnus had lost and then he's
waiting in the press conference
and Sergey gets held up in the hallway
by I guess Russia yes it was just yes
normal think that most players would
normally stock for a minute or two to
give these extra interviews for this for
Media Partners exactly yes and the
corridor on the way to the press
conference so of course Sergey just won
his game he wanted to speak about it
obviously right right and my Mac was
like went directly to the Press Center
waiting waiting she's waiting for Sergey
and this was normal sometimes it would
be the other way around so Magnus would
still give the intervention Sergey would
be there so it was the normal situation
except that Magnus just lost his game
and he wants the the press conference to
start as soon as possible and get out
yes and actually it was just two minutes
but probably it felt like two weeks and
uh yeah I mean I'm there I'm trying to
push Sergey to come quickly but so at
one point Magnus just said like okay
enough is enough and he just so we
didn't get the perspective of Magnus uh
that uh that uh maybe yeah
for this by the way guys big moment
right now okay G2 was the last move and
let's take a look because there's only
one move that draws in the position that
is Rook to H5 if he doesn't find Rook H5
H3 on the board
your king is stuck he just plundered
okay this is stunning I mean to play H3
and this was ah because
right now or King to A3 win King to A2
yes that makes much more sense why am I
putting the King on A3 when it could
potentially be for a check so King A2
and he played it with no time I mean
with without thinking yeah he still has
four minutes he should be thinking at
this point but King A2 okay so obviously
B2 and B1 and if we bring our Rook as we
wanted to before Rook G6
you're not getting to your f-pawn
Rook G6 F7 don't make a queen no
this is a stunning development
look F6 Rook takes F7 and that's it ah
Rook of standard B1 yes that's it that's
going to be an easy win
if he can find it first of all and if he
is in like in the shape to find it you
know he has I I I think Sam was rattled
after that whole situation because this
is very atypical of him right he
generally finds the best path forward
yes wow this is a huge blunder right
what a drama in this game H3 on the
board were expecting King 8 to the
Natural move just to get
out of the way of the a pawn white will
have to give up his rook and the move
that we think Sam missed Sam's expecting
Queen and then he's calculated that
after Queen he will take his King will
end up escorting this f-pawn up the
board so this is what Sam's calculated
only Hans doesn't have to make a queen
right away he can play Rook to G6 and
you don't have time to take the a pawn
that's the problem Yes actually maybe he
calculated only Rook F2 and then King G5
follows right so yeah look at six King
takes F6 in this case so what is the
difference just to show to everyone that
King G5 and you actually protect this
Pawn with your king exactly and then you
still have come to play King G6 F7 King
A3 King A2 so that after Rook G6 F7 Rook
F6 in this case if you play King G5 I
have Rook F7 and and I'm about to make a
queen so you don't have the
the possibility of Rook takes stunning
right now
wow
you know I I'm I'm kind of stunned not
only because of how it happened but the
the interlude that took place before and
I'm thinking of Jennifer is Blindness
too there was a blind spot here for a
certain rounds it's like challenging you
know
commentators you have to try to create
some sort of uh
Fortress in the position of in this end
game maybe that end game you mean with
the Rook versus the queen yes yes put
the Rook on an F5 and get the pawn to H4
and put the Rook on G5 something like
that
so Queen you're not gonna take I cannot
take because of course yes of course
Queen G1 yes so Rook F5 so Rook F5 and
you try to say Okay
I I think I understand I I think it has
to be winning too I'm sure it's a table
base kind of a moment into H5 yeah yes
you're trying to create decision okay so
check into G5 back
check I ladder check you until you get
to E3 right but then I force you to put
your king maybe on the Square you don't
on G4 G4 on G4 excuse me G4
so I feel like I've kind of achieved
uh the maximum my table base jumped up
and it said that I'm winning with the
move A6 don't ask me why and it's
probably not the only one yeah in fact
it turns out that there's quite a number
of them but I I'm not exactly sure how
you win but you're right perhaps this is
probably his best chance I think we'll
just bring the king we're just closer
and
then at some point you will be able to
win the H Pawn I cannot go if I get the
pawn to H5 Rook H7
if he finds B group of G6 B2 first
yes B2 first on the board
another rugby seven Rook G6
so in order to prove yeah
wow oh yeah this is I mean I was about
to say to claim equality I would pick up
White's King and it started that's
successful yes what about Sam let's
because this is a cold shower that you
just received right yes by this movie
you hope that this whole end game was
just simply a draw a simple drawing fact
exactly and it just proves that it's not
you just blunder your whole game and
perhaps your tournament as well as he
played F7 we are expecting Rook F6 in
the line that we've been looking at if
you don't mind a Christian uh you
mentioned that H3 was a losing move for
Sam and that he did have the move Rook
H5 that was the only movement and that
was the only move and why is that not
why would that have saved whites not an
easy one as well give me just one second
let me get those
that's why also it's like in a way
strange move to play right like kind of
you give this Pawn it's very peculiar so
you have to get the B file right right
you cannot go to the B file from h8 or
H7 because I take on H2 and that's
losing yeah
I take on H2 I pick up the root right
that's not possible the only way to get
there is a zero H5 each file now you
also have uh the threat of actually
going behind the pawn so for example if
you try to stop me I go Rook F5 but
that's problematic right exactly of
course black is still perfectly fine but
you're not going to win this one right
so after Rook to H5 it doesn't seem you
have to probably go uh behind the pawn
and now I go King to G5 and now I go to
the B file so you watch seven or h8 it
doesn't really matter yes and they're
playing very quickly to the queen
they're going versus the position what
you've
said you know you try to make a fortress
as Sam realize he's not stopping this is
a disaster
but the only way he can try to save this
game is just if he can create this
Fortress perhaps he doesn't realize that
he had this option of Rook 2 H5 perhaps
he thought that he thought it was losing
all the way all the way and that might
actually help him to try to survive this
one right
and that's why he took the king he
didn't want the king to take the punk
uh does this move H4 allow Hans to pick
up you yeah this a pawn now
maybe so how do you do
yeah
excuse me Queen G1 check is a good start
which means you won yeah yeah that came
rather quickly by Hans and he's saying
like Okay if you go to H5 I'll go check
and I can make this one and if you go to
H6 you probably have to go to H6 now
Queen to E3 Queen we need one because
you want to take H4 or A5 that's that's
a move I want to take H4 and A5 and you
cannot defend both of them but you can
maybe take only seven but then we'll
play this WOW perhaps this is actually
white
H5 on the board after Queen G1 check
the crazy part is when you think about
the undefeated players including Sam
sauvian this will be his first only loss
and again these cruel
Championship rounds where you know you
can take this great tournament you lose
your final round game and it's just sort
of like it ruins everything that you you
did before
same is true in the penultimate here you
know go talk to Jennifer right now oh
you're better better not I'd better not
talk to Jennifer in fact uh as she just
lost in her mind she spoiled the
tournament she has to get herself back
into uh
competitive Spirit your address yes sir
it's really hard tomorrow you know to
get this important mood because it's
still not over you know she still has
chances to win the tournament right
right even if you don't win even the
second play you can miss even the second
position so you still need to fight and
as you've been explaining through each
and every day there's some really nice
prizes for first exactly you don't win
first okay
second is not bad right but if you drop
your last two games and somebody writes
you a check for 12 333 dollars
you're really feeling sad uh Queen G1
King H5 on the board and uh well let's
see again I I can well understand and
move like A6 here uh but whenever the
king is cut off oftentimes you you sort
of like say okay you know you're not
going to be able to improve your
position on the next move let me improve
the position of my king and bring my
king over and I'm also thinking that
through a series of checks I could
probably win this Pawn but then I might
allow counter play with H5 so as black
I'm sitting here looking at your King on
H5 and say you know it's okay you can
stay there as long as you like I mean
let me improve my king
and
well I must say I'm still like rather
mystified by what happened and I'm more
than curious we do have some other games
going on in the ladies section Megan Fox
is still giving him the looks yes yeah I
think he's like really mad there's
something going on between these two
guys I don't know what it is I mean
Sammy is not happy no no no they seem
very uh very unhappy with each other in
fact yes maybe you know sometimes your
opponent can be cannot know you during
the game with some kind of behavior
what is happening here guys oh my God
do you remember this press conference
oh that was terrible I felt I felt that
can be three somebody will beat you did
somebody yeah exactly have the symphony
now that yeah they're they're close to
fisticuffs as we would say
um Megan is two pawns down in a bishops
of opposite color
uh middle game late late middle game
early end game position I thought that
Sophie had been winning this for some
time it's well wouldn't you know you
always have to be careful whenever I see
these Bishops on these open uh diagonals
these you know crazy things I've
witnessed uh happening here it's not as
over as I I thought and uh Alice Lee
she's enjoying a very nice uh ending
against uh yes
data I would be thinking of something
like Rook C6 I'd be wanting to play F5
myself but okay and this all-important
game uh going on uh with Hans Neiman
finally I just wanted to say oh Wonder
whoa whoa whoa is enjoying an extra pawn
and I yes seeing it's not a it's not a
mating one no no it's just but it does
look a little bit peculiar but at the
moment you play rookie too for example
to threaten Checkmate to your opponent
you get it in good shape exactly yeah
so interesting so it's a wonder to play
just a second okay can I just see this
what was going on here maybe uh if I go
after your pawns Thump Thump
uh attack on A2 and C2 well maybe if you
I I take with children okay so so this
is
or G4 doesn't matter yeah
now I don't have kinky because you play
oh you just keep doing a lot of checks
you can still get to E3 it's not clear
so I'll give you a check
we have to I give you another check in
V3 I take on h10 King D4
well now this is losing right yeah now
I've just uh I think you were too
Cooperative right about maybe here yeah
you could have maybe gone after the C2
Pawn
like king of King pardon me the C3 bond
with Rook C2 and King F3 yeah Rook C2
that's got to be a good move that's and
that even though you're two pawns on the
feels like the very very active King
King is coming to F3 should be enough
for a draw oh sure Brook G6 and root G3
Rook G6 and Rogue G3
book G3
um
so what do you do for another move I
maybe
[Laughter]
which one
now Rook D3 this three
Rook D3
and how did I improve my case yeah we're
making it uh yeah again
we're in a variation from the game
position where we traded Rooks on H5 and
went after the double pawns with Rook B1
uh uh crazy uh
well I mean uh I have to say that Sam is
doing his best he went for the Fortress
idea that you proposed uh did uh Sam but
according to my
table base it's you there's no Fortress
here
for Sam and it looks like Hans Neiman
might win
Anastasia I don't know about you but I
think it's we just take a break and try
to recover ourselves from what happened
with Arena
and uh before that maybe we can have one
more look we have to understand what
happened okay so Sam seemed to be
wanting to reach for a piece that had
been captured twiddle around with it you
know and he just inadvertently picked up
the black king yes and Hans sauce
he also broke my
Kingman
you also broke it
so give it back to me it's Mikey but
then like Sam kind of like well that's a
little bit insulting you know like oh he
should be saying I'm sorry I apologize I
apologize
let's go out
there and he says Hans keeps asking like
what what happened like what are you
doing right yes okay put my king back in
the street okay let's stop finding the
clock and that's the Arbiter
and Sam is trying to fix his King yes
okay remarkable occurrence for sure uh
unprecedented in these disrespectful U.S
championships we're going to take a
break we'll see on this other side of
the street yes
[Music]
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at St louisjessclub.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back to round 12 of US
championships the arena crash is leading
with eight and half points right now
Jennifer you and Tyler Cervantes tie are
tied for the second place with eight
points Aryan Yan has seven and we are
waiting for the results in the in the
games which are still on the way Alice
they could possibly win and get seven
and a half in the standings in the open
with two rounds two games remaining
there as well so Fabiano caronel leads
with eight points Ray Robson is just a
half of one behind with seven and half
coins linear Dominguez has seven Points
West list or six and how and we have
still some games on the way and same
stadium is playing against Hans Neiman
and depending on this game result we
will see if Sam will join the third
place or not or not now Sam Savion with
the victory could have joined Ray Robson
but he's actually losing against Hans
Neiman at the moment it doesn't look
like at all and we saw something that
was uh well you said it unprecedented as
just in a certain moment that that Hans
was thinking that Sam just kind of
inadvertently lost the Lost
concentration just picked up the king
the king of Hans and the board was just
kind of fiddling around with it and I
said hey dude man that that's my king
dude he wouldn't be getting back and it
seems like there's some tension between
the two players as they're they they had
daggers in their eyes towards one
another
the cross
he beheaded the king is that you want to
keep that yeah like yeah
so place it by yourself
[Laughter]
and I mean there is and let's go to
speak about it yes yes we're very very
very very confused like I'm just like
dude do you want to speak about it
she's like just give me the king back to
people just
so the concept enough is enough Arbiter
please come here I have a very uh very
confused now this is very important are
we going to see a shake of hands because
we might actually not see a shake of
hands don't push your luck on this one
yes I would say are we going to see a
chess boxing
because it's coming the resignation is
coming very soon times is made of a very
very important progress as he's clipped
off the A6 Pawn in a series of Queen
Maneuvers which were very nice and
probably not all that needed but it was
very very helpful so we're expecting
check
King G5
another check King has to go in front of
the pawn which is what you don't want to
do then Queen G2 and then the a pawn
just runs and that's all that's all
that's required of this game
yeah it looks really set the position of
white but what to do this really really
nice way
how to convert this position which I
mean white could make a draw at certain
point but at some point sam7 failed to
find the only move in the position
might pick up the Rook somehow Queen d8
picks up the Rook not sure
for example go King G6 you go to
industry but now King G6 was a landmine
Square yeah I can't step on uh G6 that's
for sure
so now A5 so it just protects the A5
Pawn yeah as soon as the king steps in
front of the pawn then the pawn can't
make any progress and you always want
the king to sit there so you could
okay
and a handshake yeah okay and now
they're talking so what happened now
it's important
to ask
yes it seems like all is fine that's
great they were having fun with it oh my
gosh
I'm sorry actually relieved yeah after
that you know I was expecting that it
can be something crazy but but somehow
house
said his story about something right and
then Sam was like yeah no problem
but
yes I mean it's still up here what
happened we need to find out what
exactly happened what what
a crazy moment exactly uh by the way in
uh the other game in the the re so
remaining game in the open section
Wonder Liang is still a pawn up and uh
enjoying his extra Pawn I want to say
against darus
a wonder is one of those players who is
undefeated he's a plus one a victory
would get him that much closer to the
podium still a lot of work it's not even
close to winning uh at this moment but
uh well I mean why not keep keep playing
and I would be looking at King F4 and
trying to
and that's my pot okay again I suspect
we're much closer to a draw than
anything at all in fact in the position
but still the extra pawns uh speaks for
itself it is this
what's happening in the ladies uh
Anastasia yeah Megan oh sorry we have
the position between uh if I'm not
mistaken Alice Alice yes Alice Lee and
um against Sabina so she had an extra
Pawn now I see they have this
and it doesn't look so winning as before
not at all in fact uh Sabina looks like
she's well wait a minute Rook E3 is
still an annoyance yes it is I mean like
but at least we see and then what the
phone a is not running right I was
thinking of rookie and I realized I was
about to suggest Rook A5 but then after
rookie three check King F2 Rook takes
before yeah I mean I foreign
[Music]
because if once you play rookie eight I
start pushing my Pawn probably exactly
A5 oh my God Is it okay well we can so
for example Rook E3 I'm just throwing it
out there A5 and let I don't want to
lose my pawn and do something like this
so that I will
I I'm I'm trying to trade just one Pawn
off now well I think you can go Rook a
seven first Rook A7 A3 and then E6
uh-huh there you go that that would be
the best that would be the simplest way
of drawing for me so in this position
after E5 A4 go Rook here
A3 and then go E6 and that forces the
trade yes you have to that's the trade I
I only I I don't lose upon I just trade
and it's three versus three and that's
an easy draw I think Sophie uh in the
other game might be winning
really uh against uh against Megan yeah
don't tell me Megan will lose them in a
row it's just it's been just a disaster
absolutely
and that is the game of Alice yes
indeed what a disaster in the last four
rounds yeah this is just terrible as
Sophie has just played this move Rook G4
uh she's got a mate on H1 thanks to this
long uh bishop and well we can imagine
that that just wins the game so that
leaves us with Alice Lee we think uh
championships exactly we think that Rook
E7 and E5 is enough for Sabina to draw
which he has just played Rook E7 and
then uh one remaining game
with a Wonder Liang
but look that's some progress whoa whoa
whoa so we're going to see so he traded
coupons on b-file for H Pawn so this is
supposed to be the theory is supposed to
be a draw try to make it easy I have
never had to Win It Or Draw It
fortunately for myself yeah uh I'll
probably embarrass myself uh because I
don't uh I haven't studied this ending
supposedly you you should defend it like
you would defend the Philly door
position
um and you can do the Philadelphia
position on the fourth rank as well if
you want to stay on the side and wait
for your opponent to the problem is that
your opponent is actually going to push
the a pawn it's going to go so for King
City
King on the other side
and then start pushing pot so I should
in this position be playing for A4 but
as black I should just be waiting for
that just wait yes yes
so right now you're continuing I think
and of course I
so I only know it in uh in theory
so at a certain moment I don't want to
push and allow your king I would assume
King B5 yeah would that would make it
too easy I'm not sure because you still
have C4 ideas right
it looks like dinosaurs sure I mean he
went for this position C4 maybe King C6
King B4 and it feels like you are making
some sort of progress right by the way
he's going for that King on B3 exactly
he's going to test his uh end game
knowledge
three three decisive games in the open
three drawn games in the open how will
the the coin roll will it be a fourth
draw or fourth Victory I'm not sure
I'm not sure I think it's going to be a
draw somehow and did uh did Sophie win
no not yet still
that one what a disaster for Megan I
mean she was
leading the tournament yes she was doing
amazing yes and then four games in a row
oh how does that even happen that's so
painful yeah but it's really pity and I
don't know how you feel at this moment
terrible yes just simply it's horrible
yeah like the world is against you and
everything else I mean it's just like ah
painful painful all right and Alice Lee
we're expecting a
rookie seven that's on the board we're
expecting E5 and a draw to come in this
game and again
um
broken pot ending
we've got to this position after King B4
what is the prescribed
way to draw this game again isn't it
time I mean we just have to make it take
it move by move well with the white I'm
I'm afraid White's pawns are making too
much progress I was I'm afraid that Rook
check isn't it someone that I should go
okay but that's let's get it to the game
behind position oh I I think it's our
game position
I'm in the wrong position yes so right
now how do you continue
as white as white I just played through
K1
so I would assume he's trying to go
after King B3 Rook B1 and just keep this
does it make a a sense to ask the
question of where you want your king
sure King C5 you always want your King
on C5
both of them are draw both are drawn
supposedly yes oh my goodness all right
he played King B3 and check
and he hide his King on 83 he can go
straight yes I wonder plays King A3 okay
so what if I play okay I've got a big
threat before check
yeah
maybe yes
or Rook C1 I I think both are completely
playable
Rook B4 Rook C1 and we're just being
told that Sam and Hans are actually in
the parking lot right now discussing the
game
[Laughter]
this is really good very good news okay
[Laughter]
oh my
well I mean in a U.S Championship that's
just about giving us everything we
wanted maybe even more
it's really interesting like what has
happened in King C5 on the board
so what's the uh
progress idea well I'm thinking we play
Rook B4 okay I'm thinking
rook and then I'm gonna play A4 and I'm
just gonna move my a pawn his he's going
for it until something you've if
something happens like you're gonna end
up having to get your Rook maybe
defensively minded okay still it's
unpleasant to defend descending right I
mean what has nothing to lose he's just
trying no question you are really still
suffering trying to make a draw if me
but maybe you know everything maybe
you've played this position hundreds of
times with your friends or with the
computer yes with your second and then
you are very sure about this draw
yes I think I mean like top players they
spend some time studying this type of
positions like queen against Rook you
know there is this chance to keep your
Rook far away computer finds it and to
survive for many many moves like that so
I think we even happened that some top
players they even saved positions like
that if you know the principal how to do
it which is very hard for a human being
but if you keep trying to remember this
position you you might you might really
learn how to do it so I mean the same
thing like you know that there are a
certain amount of positions which can
happen in your game sooner or later
maybe never but still
imagine that it's possible so then you
can keep studying them for some time and
like devote your time like now it's time
for endings so let's start this this
type of positions I know that I remember
once even took played against the Magnus
this game in London uh Rook ending with
two extra pawns I think which he
eventually won and he's said that okay
this position we've started let's say 10
years ago for I don't know a couple of
weeks so I kind of knew everything
because you only have a few moves that
draw if you keep the Rook on the first
rank you actually lose right so you need
to go Rook H6 Rook H7 Rook h8 or move
the king
okay not stay on the first rank or give
a check
so if we make a bad move like uh Rook at
the first this is where the a pawn goes
all the way to A6 yes
yes as Megan oh my gosh she had such a
marvelous marvelous start uh four losses
I mean Talia five wins in a row but that
means somebody's not losing uh side of
that so this is where essentially
there's this big threat of A5 in the
position which black has to address and
uh we're thinking you can move his King
he could drop his Rook back either to h8
H6 or H7 and then that's all in our
table base zone of draws but a move like
Rook it's G1 A5 and you've just lost it
suddenly the table base says oops that's
it winning
it's still unclear if white knows
everything until yet how to win this
specific but let's say now we know at
least the evaluation
and I was just saying that this end game
I haven't had it in my practice I'm
aware it's supposed to be a draw I
wouldn't want to defend it I wouldn't
want to try to win it but uh very very
difficult
I was speaking with Maurice actually the
other day and he was explaining to me
that I had this how did you like your
rest day he said not very much I said
well what did you do he said I spent six
hours on a broken
inspired by
um Alice Lee Arena Crush game he was
looking at Rook versus three pawns and
he came up with some incredibly obscure
you know triangulation to win what was
called a borderline position I didn't
know about it either and he said I mean
it took me six hours to figure it out is
this is real love purchase yeah this is
when you really love this game right you
spend six hours on the license some
endings which most probably will never
even happened in your life exactly yeah
Maurice really showed you his love his
love how much he's devoted to this game
exactly you can write the book now about
this kind of thing well he's supposed to
be writing a book book I mean that was a
that was the whole thing you know he was
saying like I I messed up my my writing
schedule uh Jump Right In and uh if you
can uh Christian explain to the viewer
some general principles what they need
for winning this ending and maybe for
drawing the ending well right now you
just need to keep the king in front of
the C Pawn so this is the most important
aspect of uh this end game now the
question is with the Rook on H1 how is
white going to make any progress if you
get the king to A3 I'm going to give you
a check and then return so by the way
and this is very very important why King
to C6 and not let's say root to G1 right
now after A5 the position is lost
because you have to go back and then I
continue going A6 I will put the Rook on
A4 and this is just going to be losing
also I can start with the move King to
B3 get my route behind the pawn push the
pawn you will have to use your resources
to capture that pawn on A6 and dashes
are simply going to be a losing Kings
and pawn and game because my king is
going to go to C4 very interesting now
this is the position that we have right
now still a draw but white has a lot of
ways to try to make progress you can try
to go C4 followed by King to B3 King to
B4 and King to A5 my guess is that once
you play the move C4
I'm going to cut you okay on H3 with the
move Rook to D3 how are you going to
continue making progress
yeah let's go so I think you would like
to get the king to A5 but unfortunately
you're not getting there let's go A5
right
I'll stay I'll wait for you okay A6 A6
and now finally I have to go
otherwise you go A7 exactly so for
example if you make any other move I go
a seven and then Rook to B8 is game over
clear right so I have to go to aha okay
and now I can advance my king yes but
now I can probably just go here right
and yeah and King B4 here and this is oh
my goodness yes you cannot take on that
the only move is King to a seven
wow to start giving checks so this is
the idea you just want to start giving
checks
that's not obvious to my eyes no no no
no no King A7 are you kidding me Rook A4
in that final position after King A7 and
then I want to go King C5 to diesel
check King C5
now I go here this is so difficult King
C6 that's what I'm saying I wouldn't
want to have to receive one C5 okay the
Palms are moving now I just wait
now I go on the side to try to give you
some tracks from the far away side wow
see oh this is scary guys yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying I I would feel
that the challenge is really really hard
this is super scary right yeah no this
is not going to be an easy defense
um a wonder is going to put a lot of
pressure on his opponent and by the way
Darius only has 49 seconds 49 seconds to
defend this end game not easy thanks God
he gets 30 seconds
yes what we've just gone through in this
table base of moves by the way forcibly
reminded me of the discussions the
contractual discussions between Gary
Kasparov and deep blue so the idea was
that Gary said look you know I'm playing
against the computer and it's got this
knowledge this perfect table based
knowledge whenever we get into position
where it's a draw and the computer knows
how to do it he'll make a draw but we
never get a position where a win the
computer will know how to do it so any
table basis the players had to play had
to accept the result yes of the table
base I see okay so something happened in
this game or what yeah
I don't think there's been a repetition
no wow
he's talking to the Players Once Again
Frank
oh
what happened
I think I think they're trying to claim
the draw because they're looking on
Leonard's Direction no it's not even
close because I'd move 69 the position
changed the pawn moved to A4 so there's
only been one two three four what hold
on maybe
is he trying to claim a drone no can't
be oops no it's not I don't think so not
even close probably he's checking yes
but it's always worthwhile to check I
think yeah
and as we sort this out let's jump to
Christian who has a guest
Hans uh another Victory attends game but
complete mad scenes towards the end of
the game what happened when Sam picked
the king I was just misunderstanding
nothing nothing too serious we had a
quarter conversation after so I assume
this there's no hard feelings there just
a misunderstanding so it wasn't just an
instinct to pick the king and start
twirling it it was he wanted to get your
attention like what was his I think the
the pin of the piece was um the king had
fallen off uh-huh so he just picked it
up but I was just a bit annoyed because
it was on my time but again I'm not
there's just no need to discuss it's
just a misunderstanding so and you guys
discussed after the game and there's
there's no no it was just a
misunderstanding misunderstanding I
don't want there's no no drama
I know you guys are desperate reviews no
no no no no drama but why he said let's
go and speak or something sorry because
it seemed like he said like let's go see
something to you at this point yes well
he wanted to towards the outside again
it's misunderstanding but the he wanted
to glue the piece ah so we wanted to go
and glue the piece yes again I was just
very confused so
you got it okay
that makes a lot of sense right now okay
let's talk the chess is much more
interesting than that absolutely let's
talk uh the game
that's a good idea yeah
talk to us about the game yeah so he
started thinking after after the semi
thrash which was just I guess he wasn't
expecting it um and he had a game
against Jeffrey so he repeated this line
with [ __ ] before and uh if I had not
tracked this that would be very foolish
uh I played Rook C8 and said which is
the best move but uh this was a novelty
as well well I guess I'm much of a novel
okay I think it's relatively known if
you're playing this opening but anyways
uh in Jeffrey's game I guess if you play
Bishop B3 and it's not that bad but it's
very inaccurate but this is actually
quite a critical line so after Rick C8
he plays um G3 Bishop B3 only move uh
Knight H5 also only move these are all
only moves and I checked this this
morning uh Bishop B3 F5 G4 this is the
first sort of uh place where after F4
things can white has the choice the
white has Bishop A7 white has Bishop D4
and white has gh5
so those are the three kind of moves
maybe they're more but from what I
remember these are three moves and let's
say after gh5
um zombie the Top Choice take take
Bishop E7 Knight takes rook f8 and goes
Rook F1 and some some stuff I don't
remember the precise I think and I think
yeah yeah position is pretty good for
you yeah and I think it's yeah I think
it's equal to a higher depth but uh
because I was checking it was equal
um this morning yeah
um so yeah a bishop before this is this
I remember this being quite challenging
yeah net F6 and I remembered H6 were G8
and it felt like he knew what he's doing
yeah he definitely knew but that
Fanatics wouldn't have moved him uh
because he started to think yeah H6 is
what I remembered and The Rook G8 Rook
G2 take on H6 I didn't remember this
specifically I stopped after uh Rook um
G8 but I I could just figure out that
after King 8 yeah 94 H25 this has to be
okay I just the bishop on B3 shuts down
the Rook on A1 and the two Bishops
combined with the Rook coming to C2 uh
should be more than enough and then uh
he played Rook G2
and I I played Bishop C5 which
yeah you know yeah can we discuss this
after the game uh H6 but no no before
um instead of Bishop C5
uh H6 India 94 94 take take Rook C4 uh
Knight D2 Rook D4 and then yeah now Rook
D7
um and Rook D1 and I wasn't quite sure
how to UNT ah Bishop B4 wow that's a
nice that's a nice little tactic yeah I
I missed that um I don't think it's
that's pretty easy to miss but I wasn't
after let's say not even I wasn't yeah
King F1 I was sort of weird you know I
wasn't sure how to untangle my pieces
um but boy the computer said it's equal
um anyways
um but I thought but I thought Bishop C5
was much yeah Bishop just felt much more
natural it's a very forcing and it gives
some opportunities to sort of mess up
because he could have played Bishop F6
gf6 and 94 Bishop D4 and did you feel
like he's I thought I thought I thought
I could all play him here um
um I I wasn't yeah there was Rook G3
Bishop B5 yeah yeah I saw this and
there's a critical idea about G3 Bishop
B5 or D3 no no Rook G3 Bishop B5 Rook D3
King 795 take take Bishop B2 and I
repeat one average C1 which is critical
um yes so that's just the only detail
that you need to see in this in this
variation
um because otherwise this is fine yeah
so he went this and I'm like what is
this what is going on yeah okay so so
you did not anticipate this move
yeah I don't think it was this was not
part of your candid movies no uh I had
there was many different emotions that I
felt after this movie Yes okay Bishop
takes so here I have I have King uh E8 I
have King E7 I um there's the torture
Cannon rules um I thought King is that
was much more natural
95 yeah so here I played okay I thought
about Bishop H5 Rook G7 Bishop buff 7
now Knight B7 and here Rook H uh G8 yeah
he told me this after the game yeah if
Rook HJ there might be Rook F7 so it's
smarter just to to play uh Rook CJ to
avoid this take take Bishop B7 and I
thought Rook G8
um
Richard one sorry check um or would you
want to and I wasn't sure if King if
yeah now you might have Bishop H5 but I
thought the point was of King D2 I could
play Rook G2 and Duke I can sort of try
to pick up the pawn but again it's it's
sort of a race this is what we discussed
after the game even but what black is
obviously to be preferred um so there
are some concrete ways but I my idea
initially was Bishop G4 and uh I thought
of H3 the the idea was to play Rook to
d8 and uh now if Bishop E3 I play Bishop
3 Rook G7 King E8
and now I thought 95 was coming
um but maybe this is not as precise what
uh 95 years coming forward yeah
something like that yeah it felt quite
dangerous
um yeah yeah so and also even yeah so
like Rook b795 for example
oh oh there's any form
yeah but anyways I thought oh yeah
that's that's quite smart yeah but
anyways I felt with uh with the bishop
and Rook the king stuck there had to be
some tactics because the Knight on C5
can't really move it was always sort of
Rook takes C3 idea for example if
um instead of the Knight B7 there's Rook
C3 and Knight d8 Rook D3
which is quite critical um there's a
Checkmate yep and um and yeah so he
plays takes yeah tick yeah and the
second game is quite nice this rookie 8
track is important to get rookie7 and I
was quite happy here
um you know B6 is an interesting I
wasn't sure this is quite a nuanced
position because I'm happy okay so it's
whenever you have these end games
putting your Pawns in a square it's very
it's a very difficult thing to to sort
of evaluate because
that you just cannot see the future
um but I felt that with B6 it wasn't
really possible for him to play um
if you didn't play A5 immediately I
thought that A4 could be weakness so I
thought a6a5 would allow him the hold so
I thought B6 was quite nice
um he goes H6 yeah Rick and Q3 yeah so
this was great and now my Rook is
activating yeah King E6 Rook D3 yeah B5
yep okay Bishop yeah okay
okay wow so Rick F4 can I just check
this so there's Rook F4
here four rookie two King D5 okay it's
probably not such a big difference in
Bishop G7 what is the what is the
difference I guess the direct is better
placed on G4 maybe there's some
and rookie eight uh okay okay yeah so
the rookie the pawns hanging okay it's a
small detail interesting yeah no I
reckon I felt very natural to me and I
also was trying to press on the clock
yeah okay yeah Bishop G7 I don't think
it's a huge difference okay okay yeah so
so let's yeah yeah so this uh
um so here I played I played um
I played Rook F7 he played Rook I'm just
where did I where did I blunder king of
one
before Oh my God I actually was playing
no oh wait with it so I have to take on
H5
I have to take an H7 and I have to take
enough two what did you calculate here
this is just so confusing to me
it was so ridiculous like for example
let's start from the position where I
play direct F7 like I'll I'll talk about
what I was like yeah so he plays rickets
Ricochet on 40 40. so we place this move
I don't know even maybe one move before
D7 yes rookie so here I have so many of
this I have Rook D2 I have B4 I have
Rook F7 so I was thinking like Rook D2
Rook h8 Rook F2 King G3 and I thought
check king of three take
there and I thought and I wasn't sure
because I was like okay let's say okay
before work h8
and
I guess the computer I just I don't know
I I guess I just got in my own head here
this is this is probably the simplest um
I just yeah I was just
too afraid didn't have the nerves here
but again I was like thinking oh maybe a
fade is coming
and I thought how do I win like
everything's covered I guess you just
have to go for respawn and then yeah and
then I just go for the pawn yeah I guess
yeah it's not easy yeah it's funny I was
looking at this but then so when I play
in the game I was also thinking okay
instead of instead of okay instead of B4
no no I play I play Rook G5 check yes so
let's go back I said Richard five so I
can play taken F2 and then King G3 and I
thought Rook takes B2
because I thought this working game oh
this freaking game is a draw okay I'm
just stupid yeah okay and and Rick B8
and B6 sort of B7 Pro yeah that makes so
much sense yeah okay
um okay I did not understand that and
I'm supposed to give a check yeah I
guess I just have to win the H2 and F2
pawns and I'm just winning but I I
thought like this was clever and they
placed he plays King H4 and I go Rook G6
yeah I just completely misevaluated this
this um but he has a very ridiculous
draw so the draw here yes B3 he has to
play yeah F6 and Rook H5
yeah that is did you guys discuss this
position after again it's funny we both
actually just missed even after the game
we just completely missed our cage five
yeah so at this point I think or
something should be going into that
variation so King A2 yes Rook B5 yes
Rook G6
F5 now
and B2
that's a good question
[Laughter]
okay I guess I guess uh I guess that is
just uh
oh okay and you're not getting
checkmates I guess I guess um you know
uh I guess humans make these mistakes by
the way I think uh we might have missed
something like A6
oh my God okay this is he had he a
little bit of he had like no time but
okay yeah yeah I can I I knew I was
playing very badly but um it was not um
okay so King A2 and after this overwhile
that is so ridiculous so can we just go
back to see how could I so the critical
mistake was Rick G6
yes can you go no no all the way back
hold it back
surgery six and so let's say I play I
need to play Rook A5 Rook H7 yes I play
Rook F2 sure and he plays King King G3
for example I have to play Rook F7 Rook
h8 yes
G4 instead King G4
for King G4 Rook F7 King G4 I just I
could not figure it out now Rook A1 sure
uh okay and I go around
yeah I guess I'm just I'm just you can't
calculate for my live streams yeah not
easy it looks very scary to me um and I
was struggling to figure it out but
yeah
options and so many weird things
happening I was getting I was just
confusing myself but yeah I should have
just been like okay I needed some of my
arrogance today to be honest I was a bit
too humble and it cost me
what happened four days ago when you
came here you said that you're going to
come to Stage a comeback and you did you
just won your last three games four days
ago yes or three days ago
after I beat uh we had the rest yeah
yeah well I think that um I have what
changed
well I think that I've just managed my
my nerves better and um I think that at
some early on in the tournament there
was a lot of pressure that I put on
myself
um to perform
um and uh combining with outside
pressure I think it just sort of really
made it difficult for me to play
um because I think that I can assure you
to everyone that playing chess as I said
during the singled cup playing chess
under sort of unique conditions or
unstable conditions is extremely
difficult
um but I think after I like lost three
games like an idiot I sort of realized
okay I'm not gonna win the tournament so
I relaxed a bit and I also sort of
realized you know I really hate losing
so much you know it keeps me up at night
so I wanted to sleep more so I decided
to start playing better chess
um and I also just hated the fact that
you know it's just I don't want to give
anyone the satisfaction of watching me
lose because I'm sure many people take
satisfaction of that uh so I also take
satisfaction into winning and seeing
people who want me to lose weight so I
took a bit of Spite and motivation and
okay you got to start playing good chess
yeah you can't be an idiot forever
yesterday you said that the tournament
has been a disaster has the tournament
improved for you do you consider it to
be a success now no why would it be a
success
okay I've won four games which is very
good and if you
for any other player would be good but
unfortunately I lose I lost three games
which I don't think anyone has
uh so okay it's definitely I think it's
a success from from considering the
circumstances it's definitely a
significance discuss
um
but of course I I hold myself to a
higher standard and I expect more of
myself and I believe that this is uh not
even close to to my peak level of play
guys any questions uh just
congratulations on your win streak Hans
and we'll be seeing you in the ultimate
round tomorrow who's gone sexually plays
tomorrow wonderful wow okay I wonder I
wonder I wonder yes so how do you feel
yourself I mean it's the last round and
actually today you managed to stop Sam
said and now he's he lost his search
position the job's not finished
you know how many games you need to win
to win an NBA series
I don't you guys aren't going to get
that joke but yes you have to win four
yeah four but the job's not finished
yeah okay all right all the best the
best indeed and I wonder uh is still
ongoing in his game with darush as uh
he's the one trying he's got the two
pawns uh to win and all the in the
ladies
everything is done honestly did make a
draw with Sabina and here are our
current standings
um
Anastasia
with all the games finished finished yes
so we have still five in a crush on the
first place and the second place we have
on the second place we have two players
Jennifer you and Charlie Cervantes with
eight points and then we have Ellis Lee
and Peru young with seven points and so
on um it's very important what will
happen tomorrow in the games of of
course Arena Jennifer and Talia to
understand who is going to win the
tournament exactly Jennifer Italia will
play each other Arena Crush will play
Anna zutansky and in the open section
our we've got one game left and here's
our current standings with One Dingo so
Fernando garanda leads with safe points
only half of one behind it has Ray
Robson with seven and half points linear
Dominguez on the on the clear third
place with seven points uh Wesley so
follow actually with six and half points
not so bad on the first position not so
bad at all as we prepare to end our
close our broadcast Christian your final
thoughts of this very what can I say
about this event I don't even I'm
running out of superlatives yeah it's
just incredible and today's round has
been incredible so many topsy-turvy uh
games of course that big match between
Jennifer you and Irina Crush that
completely changed the dynamic of the US
Women's chess championships and this
last game of Hans I mean we have so many
things to talk about but we still have
one more round the championship round
and we will be here to call all the
action tomorrow exactly well put
we will be here tomorrow please comment
the most important round tomorrow right
absolutely Anastasia I think I'm just
looking forward I'm running out of words
uh thank you all for joining us and
sharing your day be sure to tell your
friends where you've been hanging out
and we'll see you all tomorrow what's
your friends with your friends goodbye
to everyone
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited